Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlav und ich begrüße alle.
Was haben wir denn heute? Vierten Dezember zwanzig zwanzig zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Corona Weekly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Ja wieder ist eine Woche vergangen. Der Freitag wird jetzt hier langsam zum Fix, also indem wir immer aufnehmen. Samstag kommt dann die Sendung spätestens raus. Äh wie lange das immer dauert, hängt immer.
Tausend Sachen ab, vielleicht gleich zu Beginn nochmal ein kurzer.
Hinweis, den ich ja auch schon mal gegeben habe, der gerade ganz wichtig ist. UKW ist ja ein Produkt der Mieterebene, ich mache
relativ viele Podcasts und ich habe so den Eindruck, hier haben auch einige Leute zugeschaltet, die vielleicht jetzt sonst noch nicht so zu den Podcasthörern gehören oder vielleicht erst durch den Coruna Virus Update. Podcast äh in die Welt gekommen sind, das weiß ich natürlich nicht
Trotzdem haben wir
ganz gut Zuspruch, also ähm letzten Sendungen gingen so dreiundzwanzigtausend Mal weg schon in der Woche, das finde ich ziemlich bemerkenswert
Das heißt, das Interesse ist gegeben und ja, frisst auch eine ganze Menge Zeit. Ich war heute eigentlich die ganze Woche.
Dran diese Sendung hier vorzubereiten, alles mitzulesen et cetera, dir geht's ja nicht anders, Pabel, richtig, ne?
Ja, er hat dann auch zusätzlich heute das
RKI irgendwie eine Stunde zusätzlich gekostet, weil sie in den aktuellen Download einen neuen Landkreis äh reingemogelt haben, nämlich den Landkreis Aachen
und da stieg halt dann meine Software aus für die Tabelle, äh wenn als sie den Vergleich zur gestrigen Tabelle berechnet hat, war plötzlich ein Landkreis mehr da und das äh mochte der Code nicht
aber das muss sie erstmal rausfinden warum würde überhaupt ausgestiegen ist und dann wie teilweise Daten regenerieren und so, also na ja.
Ja keine Ahnung wie sie da einen.
Landkreis frei eingeben können oder oder falsch auswählen, den es eigentlich gar nicht gibt oder gar nicht mehr gibt. Na ja.
Ihre habt auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit hier die ganze Unternehmung auch zu unterstützen, tun auch viele von euch mit klugen Kommentaren, ich werde auch äh auf ein paar gleich auch noch eingehen.
Wer äh Lust hat, kann natürlich auch,
finanzielle Unterstützung machen. Ich hatte ja schon mal darauf hingewiesen, ich hatte vor ein paar Wochen angefangen zu verkünden, dass ich mein Spendenkonto wechseln muss und ja, wie das so ist mit Daueraufträgen, das dauert dann immer eine Weile.
Geht aber ganz gut voran. Ein kleiner Weg ist noch zu gehen, wenn ihr also,
regelmäßige Unterstützer der Meterebene schon seid, dann äh schaut doch bitte nochmal in den entsprechenden Link, da habe ich das nochmal genau erklärt, was es damit auf sich hat und ich würde mich sehr freuen,
findet eure Daueraufträge entsprechend anzupassen.
Vielleicht auch zu erwägen, einen überhaupt erstmal einzurichten, solltet ihr das noch nicht machen. Ansonsten bleibt das natürlich hier alles kostenfrei für alle, wie das meine Art ist.
Und ohne Werbung.
Ohne Werbung, genau. Natürlich, selbstverständlich, alles ohne Werbung, denn Werbung ist blöd.
Kommen wir zum Feedback, äh, zunächst einmal muss ich ein Nachtrag glaube ich nachreichen. Ich hatte ja,
diese Geschichte dann nochmal ausgebreitet in der letzten Sendung mit diesen ganzen Untersuchungen, Abwasser, Proben, die genommen wurden in Barcelona an anderen äh Orten und dieser.
Herumfliegenden Vermutung. Äh es könnte ja sein, dass dieses Virus schon ein bisschen länger in der Welt ist.
Habe mich da, glaube ich, ein bisschen vergaloppiert, dahingehend, als dass ich in meiner
Max gar nicht Recherche nennen, aber als ich sozusagen äh den den Hins, die mir so äh in die Timeline gespült wurden, nachging, dann doch wieder auf Artikel gestoßen bin, die schon länger zurückliegen und insofern auch schon längst eigentlich ähm.
In der Allgemeinheit zerrissen wurden oder zumindest in Frage gestellt worden und äh ich habe mich selber ein bisschen gewundert, dass die von mir verlinkten Artikel jetzt alle aus dem letzten Juli stammen und von daher äh wenig neue Substanz hatten. Ich,
hatte den Eindruck, dass dass ich auf was Neues gestoßen bin. Dem ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht so und von daher behaupte ich erstmal das äh Gegenteil. Sieht also äh nach wie vor so aus, als ob.
Das Virus in Wuan das erste Mal wirklich aufgetreten ist und äh das belegen im Prinzip auch alle Sequenzierungen, die seitdem gemacht wurden.
Ähm natürlich gibt's diese anderen Berichte, nur muss man eben auch davon ausgehen und das wurde unter anderem auch im Corona Virus Podcast auch nochmal betont. Das,
dieser Untersuchung unter Umständen einfach entweder handwerklich nicht gut gemacht waren
oder zumindest bestimmte Kontrollen, Gegenkontrollen einfach nicht hatten und das es eben sehr wohl sein kann, dass man hier größere Reaktionen hat auf andere Korona-Viren et cetera
und das alles nicht so äh sicher ist, wie es vielleicht hier und da manchen Artikeln erschien.
Ja? Auf jeden Fall, aber was ich wohl tut, was ich gesehen habe, irgendwie im äh.
August äh wurde in Tirol beschlossen halt einen Abwasserscreening, Piloten durchzuführen und.
In Luxemburg äh ist das jetzt auch geplant, soll man sagen, äh ja, an Kläranlagen, Wasserproben äh zu entnehmen und.
Auf Korona zu analysieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall.
Das ist ja auch absolut gut und sinnvoll. Hier ging's ja um Untersuchung von alten Proben und ähm.
Und da würde man denken, dass das vielleicht dann auch nochmal wiederholt wurde oder vielleicht auch in anderen Gegenden irgendwo ähm mal gemacht wurde, werden sehen.
Genau, aber dazu habe ich halt einfach kein Material, falls ihr da was äh wisst, lasse ich mich gerne eines Besseren belieren. Gut, aber das ist ja auch nicht das Wichtigste, sondern das Wichtigste erstmal sind natürlich die aktuellen.
Zahlen, Pavel, was hat sich denn getan, vor allem in Deutschland.
Ja. Also ähm wenn man auf ganz Deutschland guckt, hat sich äh sehr wenig getan, so in der in der Summe. Wir sind.
Bisschen zurückgegangen bei den Neuinfektionen äh der sieben Tagesschnitt liegt jetzt bei
knapp achtzehntausend, also ein bisschen drunter, also achtzehntausend Neuinfektionen pro Tag äh und der Rückgang entspricht einem sieben Tage er von ungefähr null Komma neun neun, also.
Tisch eins und wir sind, was jetzt die Institanz pro hunderttausend Einwohner angeht bei hundertdreiundfünfzig deutschlandweit
Und die ist irgendwie um ein oder zwei
Ruhepersonen runtergegangen, also von ja von hundertfünfundfünfzig auf hundertdreiundfünfzig oder so, also da,
tut sich quasi nichts, da bewegen wir uns mehr oder weniger seitwärts.
Leider trifft es nicht auf die Zahl der Toten zu, also in den vergangenen sieben Tagen wurden zweitausendvierhundertachtundvierzig neue Todesfälle gemeldet und
Das ist ein absoluter Sieben-Tages- äh Rekord und da ist bislang auch nicht zu erkennen, dass sich das.
Auf Deutschland bezogen äh verlangsamt. So ja also anderen Worten.
Insgesamt tut sich in Deutschland nichts, wenn man alles zusammenzählt. Das stimmt aber nicht, wenn man,
die Bundesländer hinein guckt, weil da sieht man jetzt,
doch ein deutliches Auseinanderfallen der Entwicklung in den Bundesländern, weil wir etwa in Hamburg, Berlin und Niedersachsen.
Deutlich fallende Neuinfektion haben, also um fünfundzwanzig Prozent ungefähr äh innerhalb einer Woche, was einem R, was einem sieben Tageser von null Komma neun
ungefähr entspricht,
umgekehrt in Sachsen, Sachsen-Anhalt, Saarland und Bremen geht's weiter deutlich nach oben.
Und nach wie vor sind fast überall aus Herrn Mecklenburg, Vorpommern und Schleswig-Holstein sind die Institutionen deutlich über,
fünfzig auf hunderttausend und wir haben jetzt auch noch
ein Novum, an das ich mich so gar nicht erinnern kann, nämlich dass wir in unseren Top dreißig mal ein Bundesland.
Gefunden haben in meiner Risikotabelle,
Sachsen ist jetzt als gesamtes Bundesland auf Platz fünfzehn. Äh wenn also wenn Sachsen ein Landkreis wäre, dann gibt es nur vierzehn Landkreise, die ähm,
ja schwerer betroffen sind als Sachsen und das will was heißen
ansonsten ja Bayern äh ist auch noch äh zehn Mal in den Top Ten vertreten mit Landkreisen, dreimal Thüringen, zweimal Brandenburg und bisschen Rheinland-Pfalz und Baby. So.
Also mit anderen Worten äh es entwickelt sich schon jetzt eine gewisse Schere. Äh,
einige Landkreise da ähm,
geht's mehr oder weniger ungebremst nach oben und in anderen Landkreisen beziehungsweise Bundesländern geht es jetzt deutlich nach unten und erfreulicherweise gehört Berlin äh zu den.
Bundesländern oder ist sogar das Bundesland? Ähm wo die Zahlen sich am schnellsten nach unten.
Wickelt haben in den letzten vierzehn Tagen, also Vorwoche verglichen mit der Woche davor.
Achtzehn Jahre in Berlin. Oh, ich muss mich korrigieren. Ähm Hamburg,
sind die Zahlen sogar auf sechsundsiebzig Prozent und in Niedersachsen auf achtzig Prozent gefallen. Also Berlin.
Berlin auf dreiundachtzig Prozent, also Berlin ist sozusagen das drittbeste äh Land, was den Rückgang angeht,
Allerdings und das ist äh wirklich bemerkenswert der Landkreis.
Friedrichshain Kreuzberg ist tatsächlich von allen Landkreisen die da sind derjenige mit dem krassesten Rückgang.
Haben sich die Infektionen jetzt mehr als halbiert in Friedrichshain Kreuzberg und warum das.
Mag man jetzt spekulieren äh aber wenn man jetzt auf die Altersverteilung für ganz Berlin guckt und das wird sich in in Friedrichshain Kreuzberg wahrscheinlich noch krasser
entwickeln ist, dass in der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig
doch die Institution sehr stark zurückgegangen äh sind,
und leider aber bei achtzig plus äh immer noch weiter nach oben gehen, aber das sind halt nicht ganz nicht ganz so viele. In den anderen Altersgruppen.
Mehr oder weniger konstant oder leichter äh Rückgang. Aber kann also sagen, dass.
Jetzt für beliebt zumindest der Rückgang in den Zahlen vor allem in der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig beziehungsweise zwanzig bis dreißigjährigen die halt.
Bislang am höchsten lagen bei den Institzen sind jetzt nur noch an äh zweiter Stelle nämlich so um die zweihundertfünfzig.
Während jetzt ist bei den über achtzigjährigen bei vierhundert pro zehntausend über achtzigjährige
äh liegt. Was halt heißt, dass wir in Berlin auf jeden Fall und auch im Bund wahrscheinlich noch etwas länger
steigende Zahlen an Toten sehen werden, als man das jetzt rein nach der Zahl der Infektionen oder Gesamtinfektionen
sagen würde.
Ja, es gelingt einfach nicht,
oder nicht ausreichend da die Älteren entsprechend zu schützen und und kann halt vermuten, das weiß ich aber jetzt nicht genau, dass es halt nach wie vor in Altersheimen äh Altenheimen, wir sind darauf hingewiesen, worden,
heißt ja Altenheim, weiß gar nicht warum ich das äh immer anders sage. Ähm ja das.
Dass es nicht gelingt, das das Büros dort rauszuhalten. Zumindest nicht in ausreichendem Maße. Warum auch? Woran auch immer das liegen mag, das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber ist eine Erfahrung, die man in allen
Ländern äh gemacht hat, wenn die Institutionen nach oben gehen. Also sogar gehört sagen, dass es sowas wie ein Ping Pong Effek,
äh gegeben hat in vielen Ländern, dass halt erst irgendwie die Jungen, die haben's dann in die Alten getragen, die haben's dann wieder zurück äh äh zu den Jungen getragen und so
schien das wohl auch ja bisschen hin und her zu pendeln,
Also demografisch ist das äh jedenfalls eine Katastrophe, dass die Institutionen bei achtzig Plus so hoch gegangen sind und das war.
Ja in der ersten Welle hatten wir da auch einen Piek, aber den ganzen Sommer über.
Eigentlich waren die unauffällig bis noch vor vier, fünf Wochen äh hat sich die Altersgruppe achtzig plus.
Gehörte zu den niedrigsten und jetzt ganz schnell innerhalb von fünf Wochen. Also es ist in fünf Wochen passiert, dass jetzt plötzlich äh ja in den in den die ganzen Alten auf einmal erkranken. Mir ist das.
Bisschen ein Rätsel.
Ja, zumal wir jetzt diesen Logdownlight eigentlich seit einem Monat haben, so. Aber da werden wir gleich nochmal drüber reden, ist äh noch nicht so die Folgen hat, die wir uns äh wünschen würden.
Vielleicht noch um Deutschland jetzt abzuschließen zu den Testzahlen. Es wurden ja vor vier Wochen die Testkriterien geändert,
Frier, unter welchen Bedingungen getestet wird? Daraufhin sind,
dann erstmal die Tests deutlich zurückgegangen, während wir vorher äh Anstiege hatten so ähm.
Ja gehen die Zahl der Tests in den letzten vier Wochen permanent zurück, wobei sich das weitgehend stabilisiert hat jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen, aber ähm ja
Wir haben trotzdem jetzt zwanzig Prozent weniger Tests, als wir in Kalenderwoche vierundvierzig, also vor einem Monat
noch äh noch wöchentlich hatten. Was aber ein erfreuliches Signal ist, ist dass die positiven Quote ganz, ganz leicht
gefallen ist um ein halbes Prozent von neun Komma drei vier auf neun Komma zwo acht, was,
zumindest ein Signal dafür ist, dass die Zahlen, die wir alle vorher genannt haben für Deutschland jetzt nicht mehr durch geänderte Testkriterien allzu stark verzerrt sind
aber nach wie vor ein Problem ist
positiven Quote sollte nicht über fünf Prozent liegen, das ist eine Empfehlung der Weltgesundheitsorganisation, weil man sonst
ungenau wird und einfach die Dunkelziffer in die Höhe geht und wir sind doppelt so hoch fast. Wir müssten eigentlich doppelt so viele Tests machen damit die Zahlenqualität im Rahmen dessen ist auf
man sich eigentlich geeinigt hat oder dass was wünschenswert wäre und auch wenn's in anderen Ländern noch deutlich höher ist.
Äh ist das nicht schön, dass es nicht mustergültig.
Vielleicht bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei Deutschland und fragen uns äh in dem Zusammenhang halt einfach mal funktioniert dieser Logdownlight.
Den wir jetzt seit dritten November haben, also seit einem Monat, äh knapp fünf Wochen.
Funktioniert der oder funktioniert der nicht? Ich meine er funktioniert insofern als dass wir halt keinen Anstieg haben, also bei den bei der Zahl der Neuinfektionen. Das ist so, sagen wir mal eingefangen worden.
Aber wenn wir auch nicht müde zu betonen, es ist halt einerseits ein sehr langsamer, quälender Vorgang, es geht nicht abrupt
Es geht nicht so schnell wie wir das bei dem großen Lokdauern im März gesehen haben. Klar, der war natürlich auch sehr viel umfangreicher, Schulen geschlossen et cetera. Aber
auch eine richtige Trendwende lässt sich halt noch nicht herauslesen, sodass wenn jetzt eben so diese übliche Lokdown-Müdigkeit
einsetzen, ja? Wir haben jetzt Weihnachten vor der Tür, wissen was das bedeutet, sehr viel mehr Bewegung im Land und Leute wollen sich treffen, die sich halt vielleicht derzeit nicht treffen
dass ich Zweifel habe, ob wir mit dieser Strategie so äh gut fahren.
Als das, was du gesagt hast, stimmt, es gibt äh zudem aber auch noch zwei Merkwürdigkeiten.
Bei diesem Lokdown einmal hat der RWT begonnen, schon zu fallen.
Deutlich bevor irgendwelche Maßnahmen getroffen wurden. Das hatten.
Hatten, den Effekt hatten wir aber auch.
Den Effekt hatten wir auch im März
Allerdings, es war ja diesmal auch ein bisschen anders. Wir hatten ja zum einen schon einen Teilockdown und ich weiß, dass die.
Läden noch am Abend vor dem letzten Lokdown, also am am ersten elften müsste das gewesen sein und ab zweiten elften war der Lokdown, war alles noch brechend voll.
Und es war auch nicht so viel Panik und nicht so viel Alarm und so insofern ist es ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Und dann ist allerdings der sieben Tage Erwert viel langsamer gefallen und.
Leider eben auch viel früher aufgehört zu fallen, als bei.
Der ersten Welle und dummerweise äh sind wir jetzt äh bei eins oder knapp unter eins im Moment so null Komma neun neun und oder null Komma,
neun acht hängen wir jetzt fest und das jetzt seit fast ja seit zwei Wochen.
Seit gut vierzehn Tagen äh passiert da nicht wirklich viel.
Ja und es ist auch so.
Klar, so in der Summe, ja? Geben sich jetzt mal Zahlen, die so mindens knapp unter so das, was man eigentlich haben will, äh also also man will unter eins sein, ja, jetzt sind wir bei null Komma neun neun.
Das reicht halt nicht, um irgendwie nennenswert was nach unten zu ziehen, ne? Also wir bräuchten halt eigentlich, was weiß ich, null Komma acht, null Komma sieben irgendwas Drastisches, um in absehbarer Zeit, also in zwei, drei Wochen, gerade jetzt im Hinblick auf.
Weihnachten, ja was in drei Wochen ist,
die Zahlen in einen Bereich zu kriegen, wo er sagen kann, okay, alles klar, noch ein paar Schutzmaßnahmen und dann passt das irgendwie schon. Und äh das haben wir nicht und was halt,
auch zu sehen ist, ist eine Auswertung hier von Dirk Pesslers, äh die ich gefunden habe. Du könntest, glaube ich, mit deiner Tabelle was Ähnliches machen.
Dass wenn man jetzt einfach mal nur nach Landkreisen geht und schaut, wo steigt's, wo äh geht's runter, dass eigentlich,
im Mittel ist das halt so, du hast immer genauso viele Landkreise, wo es schlechter wird und
versus Landkreise, wo es besser wird. Das heißt, gerade, wenn du mal irgendeinen positiven Effekt hast, jetzt können wir über Berlin gerade jubeln, ja, super, hier Kreuzberg kriegt sich äh in den Griff und singt, äh war ja auch bitter nötig,
Aber es gibt dann halt wieder andere, die es dann wahrscheinlich doch wieder zu locker nehmen und schnell äh sich die Infektion wieder in die Menge reinholen, um dann eben entsprechende Fortschritte an einer anderen Stelle ähm ja gleich wieder abzuräumen.
Ja in der Tat die.
Zahl der Landkreise, wo es steigt und die, wo es sinkt, halten sich ungefähr die Waage,
So und das war wohl bei der ersten Welle, da haben wir leider die Zahlen nicht.
Ähm jedenfalls nicht, nicht nicht in dem äh Detailierungs äh Grad, äh wie wir sie eigentlich bräuchten. Jedenfalls äh hatten wir da wesentlich mehr Landkreise, wo.
Nichts los war oder die Zahlen äh nach unten gegangen ist. Also wir haben jetzt,
einfach die Situation, es ist in der Fläche und es springt sozusagen von Landkreis zu Landkreis und wenn genau, wenn der eine Landkreis nach oben
nach unten geht, äh sehen wir dafür einen anderen Landkreis, wo es nach oben geht. Jetzt hoffen, dass sich das Gewicht bald verschiebt, aber im Moment.
Halten sich eben äh die in etwa die Waage und ja insofern können wir jetzt nicht auf ein.
Schnellen Rückgang in der Fläche hoffen und was wir erreichen müssten, nur mal ähm jetzt so äh,
ein paar Leitwerte, ich hab,
jetzt gerade die Tabelle nochmal äh oder die Grafen nochmal erneuert. Ich habe einfach mal geguckt äh wie müsste ein R aussehen oder unter welchem R müssten wir bleiben, damit wir.
Bis.
Zeitpunkt X ähm unter fünfzig fallen und jetzt sieht's so aus, wenn wir es zu Weihnachten schaffen wollen, müssten wir.
Sofort einen R von unter null Komma acht haben bei null Komma acht würden wir genau am, ja am dreiundzwanzigsten zwölften unter die fünfzig kommen.
Ähm wären's null Komma acht fünf schaffen wir es bis Silvester und mit null Komma neun,
bis Mitte Januar ungefähr. Äh also.
Anderen Worten Berlin da liegen wir auch in der Größenordnung ungefähr was die Institzen angehen heißt das wenn wenn's in Berlin so bleibt.
Wie es ist mit dem RW sind wir in Berlin Mitte Januar unter fünfzig ähm.
Bei null Komma neun fünf. So dauert's dagegen bis Ende Februar.
Anfang März bis man unter fünfzig kommt und alles was sich irgendwie über null Komma neun fünf eigentlich abspielt ähm ist vor Juni.
Kaum damit zu rechnen, äh dass ja, also ist in absehbarer Zeit,
passiert da nichts. Also bei bei null Komma neun acht beispielsweise ja gibt's kein Schnittpunkt vor Mitte Juni bereits, das heißt null Komma neun sechs oder so
äh aber ja natürlich wird der, weil ich höre die Kritik immer wieder, ja, also kann's jetzt nicht einfach einen festen Ehrwert nehmen, der natürlich wird der steigen oder sinken, aber man kann sagen, okay, wenn wir im Schnitt unter dem Wert bleiben,
dann.
Ungefähr kann man das, sag mal als idealisierte Prognose sehen und der Punkt ist für Deutschland.
Sind wir jetzt noch nirgendwo äh.
Dass Lockerungen passieren können, aber wir sehen halt, dass durchaus in einzelnen ähm Landkreisen oder auch Ländern tatsächlich Lockerungen,
im Januar ähm möglich sein könnten,
so, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir nehmen jetzt die äh fünfzig
Neuerkrankung pro hunderttausend als Maßstab, dass wenn wir da runtergefallen sind, dass wir beginnen zu lockern. Ich selber würde ja eher warten, bis man auf unter zwanzig,
runter ist, weil natürlich erfahrungsgemäß dann beim Lockern
es erstmal auf jeden Fall einen Ausschlag nach oben gehen wird und man will einfach Reserven haben, man will nicht gleich wieder die neue dritte.
Welle beginnen.
Ja der Lokdown Light ist ja jetzt auch verlängert worden schon von der Bundesregierung bis zum zehnten Januar, damit war eigentlich zu rechnen, also das war ja hier schon eigentlich von Anfang an unsere,
Meinung, ne? Dass das äh unvermeidlich ist und jetzt ist es halt auch äh gekommen und ich finde es ein bisschen mühsam zuzuschauen.
Wie eigentlich so unser föderales System äh sich hier so ein bisschen gegenseitig die Karten zu legen scheint. Also es ist ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung.
Wenn das jetzt alles nur auf Bundesebene entschieden würde, wir da schon sehr viel weiter hätten kommen können, aber dass es dann einfach so auf Landes äh Fürsten ähbene einfach keinen rechten Konsens zu geben schein.
Ja hm.
Bin schon in dieser dieser merkwürdigen Situation, dass ich mir so diesen Diskurs der Bundespolitik anschaue und die ganze Zeit denke so, oh Gott, jetzt bin ich irgendwie auf einmal Team Söder.
Damit hätte ich irgendwie auch nicht gerechnet in meinem Leben.
Ja
Was ich bemerkenswert finde ist, wie nah man sich jetzt in Berlin gerade an die Katastrophe herangetastet hat, ja, in Berlin waren ja die.
Auslastung der Intensivstation und.
Ja der Krankenhäuser durch Korona bereits im roten Bereich, also über fünfundzwanzig Prozent, wo man gesagt hat, das ist
Das ist kritisch und das hätte nicht mehr so weitergehen können,
Jetzt sieht es so aus wie in Berlin, dass es sich stabilisiert hat, also die Belegung der Intensivbetten mit Corona Patienten geht in Berlin leicht zurück und wie gesagt, Berlin war am schlimmsten
Sofern ist man äh da jetzt an der Katastrophe mal wieder gerade knapp vorbei geschrammt. Keine Ahnung, wie es in Sachsen.
Laufen wird, das scheint mir da nicht so äh optimal zu sein, aber das müssen wir halt
abwarten, äh wie sich das da entwickelt ähm mit dem Gesundheitssystem, aber
Es sieht im Moment zumindest so aus, als wenn wir einen Zusammenbruch unseres Gesundheitssystems zumindest vermieden haben durch diese.
Politik äh durch diesen Lokdown leit. Was wir uns aber erkauft haben für das Leid.
Damit.
Leid sein kann, sind wir jetzt auf Werten bei den Toten, die gerade an Corona äh sterben, die eigentlich nicht.
Äh tolerierbar sind. Aber dennoch irgendwie toleriert werden immer noch.
Und das ist fatal. Also im Moment sterben glaube ich in,
vierzehn Tagen mehr Leute als in der ersten Welle insgesamt gestorben sind.
Ja, so ein ein Jumbo-Flugzeugabsturz pro Tag.
Ja, das ist irgendwie was, was regen wir uns immer auf, wenn ein Flugzeugabsturz, wenn äh ein Bus mit alten Leuten von der Autobahn abkommt und sich überschlägt und alle tot sind. Und jetzt haben wir das halt am laufenden Meter
täglich quasi und das ist äh nicht gut.
Das geht eigentlich nicht,
aber ja, ich meine man hört hier und da vereinzelt Aufschreie auch in der Politik, aber das scheint, wenn's wenn's darum geht, irgendwie.
Zu entscheiden zwischen, ich sage mal, alten und der Wirtschaft äh scheint so zu sein, dass in unserer Gesellschaft die Wirtschaft gewinnt.
Ich meine der Einwand kann schnell kommen, ne? Natürlich wird auch durch den Niedergang der Wirtschaft viel Leid, ja, Eleid erzeugt
und hat natürlich auch langfristige äh Folgen, auch der Lok dann als solches haben wir auch schon tausend Mal besprochen, ja, psychische Probleme, äh Unternehmen, die halt dann wirklich pleite gehen, die einfach ihr Businessmodell verlieren et cetera, PP,
Natürlich ist das ein fortwährendes Abwägen in der Politik und es ist sicherlich auch keine einfache Entscheidung. Nur in der Summe merken wir halt immer wieder,
Eigentlich kommt jetzt beides zu Schaden, ja? Dadurch, dass wir es halt so lange rausgezögert haben und die Maßnahmen nicht voll angezogen haben, zieht es sich jetzt einfach noch mehr in die Länge, ja? Jetzt haben wir halt diesen Zustand von zwei,
drei Monaten, die das sich hinziehen wird und.
Ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht, dass wir im Januar am zehnten Januar hier sitzen werden, sagen wir noch, jetzt ist wieder alles supi, ja, weil dann kommt halt Weihnachten noch äh rein und dann,
wird sich das Elend wahrscheinlich noch bis tief in den Februar ähm verlängern.
Und äh und dann ist halt auch nicht viel gewonnen. Also das dann also man hat dann sozusagen beides, ja? Also man hat hohe Todeszahlen die ganze Zeit und dann hat man halt eine fortgesetzte Belastung der Wirtschaft und das ist das, was mich.
An der Stelle so ein bisschen ärgert.
Gut, was wir auch schon tausend Mal festgestellt haben, ist äh dass natürlich es besser gewesen wäre für die Wirtschaft und für uns alle.
So, wenn man es gar nicht zu dieser zweiten Welle, wenn es gar nicht dazu gekommen wäre.
Was man in der Hand gehabt hätte, also sie war jetzt nicht unausweichlich.
Sondern die hat sich über Wochen abgezeichnet und man hätte einfach mal mit zwei Wochen dichtmachen.
So mit diesem Wellenbrecher Shutdown.
Vermeiden können oder die Zeit, die wir jetzt im Lokdown leid verbringen, um Monate verkürzen können, ja? Um ich meine, wir sind jetzt,
einen Monat drin so und sind immer noch auf dem Gipfel. So, es heißt, es wird mindestens ein Monat.
Aber eher zwei Monate oder drei Monate dauern bis wir wieder da sind, wo wir, wo wir mal waren, wenn alles so
geht oder läuft
wie man sich das erhofft, so das heißt diese Strategie im Moment, diese eher kurzsichtige Strategie, nicht in den harten Lokdown
zu gehen, birgt natürlich erhebliche Risiken, nämlich äh wenn die Zahlen dann plötzlich steigen
Durch Weihnachten oder durch irgendwelche Änderungen beim.
Wetter oder andere Faktoren, das wissen wir nicht. Dann, wie du richtig sagst, haben wir nämlich,
beides, dann haben wir einen ewigen Logdownlight und dazu dann auch noch wahrscheinlich zwei bis sechs Wochen totalen Logdown mit,
geschlossenen Geschäften und äh geschlossenen Schulen. Das kann immer noch drohen. Also das ist nicht abgewendet im Moment.
Und du richtig sagst die Toten, die hat man jetzt äh sagen geopfert in der Hoffnung, dass es dazu nicht kommen wird.
Und im Moment sieht es so aus, als wenn es aufgehen könnte, aber es kann auch anders kommen.
Was ich nicht hoffe, aber.
Ja und es wirft natürlich dann auch noch eine ganze Menge andere Probleme auf sich, weil natürlich auch diese ganzen Ausfälle. Das muss auch alles äh finanziert werden. Ja, man geht jetzt auch.
Von dieser Regelung des wir zahlen euch jetzt mal den Vorjahresumsatz hinzu, wir zahlen euch die Fixkosten.
So habe ich das zumindest verstanden. Rein bürokratisch
so wie ich das höre, da eine ganze Menge Probleme, also viel von dem, was zugesagt wird, findet so effektiv äh nicht statt oder kommt zu spät oder ist halt irgendwie schwierig und
gerade so Cafés in Restaurants stehen dann auch immer so ein bisschen vor diesem Problem äh schlage ich mich jetzt irgendwie mit mit Straßenverkauf so ein bisschen durch und.
Äh irgendeinen Umsatz zu machen oder hoffe ich drauf, dass äh diese Zahlung rechtzeitig kommen. Ja, dann kann man irgendwie nicht so richtig beides machen und das einfach alles ein bisschen.
Schwierig, aber ich hab mich jetzt da in die konkreten wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen ehrlich gesagt nicht so tief reingewurschtet, ist halt einfach nur auffällig, dass.
Eigentlich mit dieser Situation keiner so richtig zufrieden sein kann. Das das ist eigentlich so das Ding. Also man hat jetzt einfach mehr Leid durch durch Leid,
Schauen wir doch vielleicht mal, äh, wie es unseren europäischen äh äh Nachbarn oder anderen ähm Ländern überhaupt so geht, ohne jetzt hier vielleicht die komplette äh Liste durch äh rattern zu lassen, was würdest du denn.
Als interessant empfinden, auf welches Land man mal schauen sollte. Du hast ja immer deine spezielle Brille bei Tschechien.
Und Tschechien war ja nun extrem stark betroffen und hat auch äh einen kräftigen Lokdown gemacht, der wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe jetzt gerade gelockert wird.
Richtig, also Tschechien.
So gehörte ja zu dem war ja das zweitschlimmste Land in der zweiten Welle jetzt nach Belgien mit einer sieben Tagesinstitenz von ähm über tausend.
So und haben sich jetzt.
Runtergearbeitet mittlerweile ganz gut und.
Liegen aber immer noch deutlich höher als Deutschland.
Derzeit so, also Tschechien liegt normal locker auf die Zeilen gucken.
Bei den Infektionen meins jetzt.
Bei den bei den Neuinfektionen.
Schickt Tschechien. Ich kann's beim doppelten äh vierzig Prozent über dem, wo wir jetzt liegen und lockert gerade, was eigentlich.
Ihr Einladung ist eine neue Welle loszutreten im Januar. Jetzt bis Weihnachten,
sich nochmal alles schön durchmischt. Das sieht so aus, als wenn Tschechien jetzt.
Nichts gelernt hat und den Fehler vom Sommer nochmal wiederholt. Allerdings.
Was man auch feststellen kann ist das merkwürdigerweise sich in den ja letzten zwei bis drei Wochen der Rückgang.
Der Neuinfektion deutlich verlangsamt wird. Also die Kurve wird wieder flacher.
Das heißt, dass der Lokdown eigentlich bereits vor drei Wochen.
Aufgehört hat so zu wirken wie er in den fünf Wochen davor gewirkt hat. Das heißt entweder,
haben die Leute.
Lockerungen auch vierzehn Tage vorweggenommen einfach ohne dass sie verkündet wurden, sondern in Erwartung äh so, oh die Zahlen gehen runter, wir blockern jetzt einfach mal.
Selber so unser Verhalten.
Wir machen uns jetzt mal locker.
Ja, wir machen uns jetzt mal locker und das heißt, vielleicht war auch diese Lockerung fast unausweichlich oder
Man hat sich gesagt, okay, der Lokdown bringt gerade eh nichts mehr, die Zahlen gehen nicht weiter runter. So und das ist viel zu frustrierend. Und es ist Weihnachten, deswegen machen wir halt jetzt auf.
Und bin gespannt, wie lange das gut geht,
aber das zeigt natürlich auch, dass es jetzt nicht so eine goldene Regel gibt nach dem Motto, na ja, wenn's denn erstmal bergab geht, dann.
Geht's halt auch erstmal weiter in den Keller, weil je weniger Infektionen, desto besser ist das dann wieder beherrschbar und trackbar und so, aber in den Größenordnungen.
Bringt das irgendwie gar nichts. Also es ist auch nicht nur in Tschechien so, sondern in vielen anderen Ländern auch.
Belgien sich sich ähnliches äh oder in Frankreich, dass halt ja.
Das nicht mehr weiter runter geht und die Institzen weiterhin eigentlich auf einem viel zu hohen Level ist. Frankreich stagniert auch seit einer Woche allerdings auf etwas geringfügigerem Niveau als als wir,
So in Spanien liegt auch drunter. So also
aber auch da geht's nicht weiter zurück, sodass wir dass es jetzt schon so aussieht, als wenn Europa sich
irgendwo auf einem wahrscheinlich sehr hohen oder viel zu hohen Niveau im Dezember stabilisieren wird
und dann möglicherweise nochmal im Januar oder Februar nochmal durch eine dritte Welle gehen wird. Das
Sieg jedenfalls den Zahlen nach gerade für mich so aus.
Also im Europavergleich sind wir mit äh Deutschland äh na ja im gewissen Maße unter äh durchschnittlich, wenn ich jetzt mal,
wenn man so einfach die Tabelle anschaue, welche europäischen Länder sind denn jetzt eigentlich von Neuinfektionen am meisten betroffen? Ich sage gleich nochmal was zu den
äh Toten. Haben wir äh ganz neue Spitzenreiter, ja? Also Kroatien geht's gerade äh richtig ab, also ungefähr vierfache von dem, was wir haben. Luxemburg ist es eh.
Serbien ist am krassesten im Moment.
Serbien, wieso habe ich den habe ich Serbien hier in meiner Liste? Oh, ich habe glaube ich Serbien vergessen. Aha, gut, dass du das erwähnst.
Stimmt Serbien. Oh ja, oh Serbien ist ja noch schlimmer. Oh Gott, das ist ja das Fünffache von von Deutschland. Ist klar.
Also es spielt sich viel im Osten ab. Luxemburg ist noch dabei, Slowenien,
Litauen, Ungarn, Schweden auch immer noch, das Doppelte von äh Deutschland, so Österreich kommt nicht so richtig zur Ruhe, auch Schweiz, Bulgarien, also.
Da es noch sehr viel mehr Infektionsgeschehen, ne und es ist einfach die einzigen Länder, die so halbwegs sagen, wo man sagen kann so, ah okay, kriegst grade noch so hin, ist so Finnland. Ähm Norwegen.
Island und Irland so, ja.
Genau und wenn man sich die Todeszahlen anschaut, was ja mehr das Geschehen von vor ein paar Wochen äh reflektiert, da ist dann wiederum Slowenien ganz weit vorne und Bulgarien, also da,
ist äh derzeit das Geschehen im Vergleich zu Deutschland äh.
Ungefähr so das fünffache Todesraten, ja? Bulgarien immer noch das Vierfache äh auch Ungarn, auch Kroatien, auch Polen, also.
Wir argumentieren mal wieder von so einer einer einer Position des des des des ähm Vergleichs stehen wir relativ,
da nur an sich ist es halt trotzdem schon untragbarer Zustand und ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie die Debatten in den anderen Ländern laufen, Europa
ist insgesamt da einfach instabil und,
alle Vergleiche mit United States brauchen wir da gar nicht erst anzufangen. Es ist halt einfach eine Ruhrpott-EZ schlimmer. Also der Westen kommt nicht.
Sogar UK liegt irgendwie unter dem Europadurchschnitt, ja.
Aber immer halten. Naja, also.
Wollen euch jetzt hier auch nicht mit äh tausend Zahlen ähm langweilen. Ähm aber es ist noch.
Noch viel zu tun und es ist vor allem auch nicht so richtig zu erkennen, dass so eine gemeinsame Strategie gefahren wird oder dass die EU da einen großen Einfluss hat oder so gut Serbien betrifft, dann wiederum die EU nicht.
Ich glaube alle setzen so ein bisschen ihre Hoffnung auf die Impfstoffe. Wollen wir dann mal gleich zu dem Thema auch überwechseln.
Ja. Ich denke.
Da ist wirklich 'ne Menge passiert.
Zunächst einmal, also wir haben ja um das Feld nochmal kurz klar zu machen, wer das so nicht verfolgt. Wir haben im Prinzip.
Sind das jetzt so,
vier Kandidaten, die derzeit vor einer Zulassung stehen, beziehungsweise diese schon äh beantragt haben oder auch schon erhalten haben. Wir haben die beiden hier auch schon vorgestellten
relativ modernen MRNA, Impfstoffe von moderner aus den USA und in Biontech äh
Wirkstoff hier aus aus Deutschland, der zusammen mit Pfeiser in USA entwickelt wurde.
Die äh sind jetzt sozusagen auf dem Weg der Zulassung, also moderner hat jetzt die Zulassung bereits beantragt in den USA und in der EU.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass das in den USA relativ schnell geht
Wir hatten das, glaube ich, hier zuletzt diskutiert, als die ihr Zwischenergebnis äh veröffentlicht haben. Moderne hat mittlerweile auch
Studie, die Phase drei dahingehend abgeschlossen, als das eben die erforderlichen einhundertsechsundneunzig Fälle
zusammengekommen sind.
Also nochmal zur Erklärung, man gibt den Impfstoff an möglichst viele Leute und dann beobachtet man halt wer wird davon äh krank und man hat halt so eine eins zu eins Verteilung mit
Placebo und ähm normalem Impfstoff.
Da sind dreißig über dreißigtausend Leute in diesem Test mit äh drin gewesen und jetzt gab's eben diese hundertsechsundneunzig,
Fälle, wo halt Leute krank geworden sind und dann schaut man halt, okay, habe ihr den richtigen äh Impfstoff bekommen oder seid ihr in der Placebo-Gruppe und der über
große Anteil ist in der Placebo-Gruppe, das heißt wir haben eine extrem hohe Wirksamkeit, die jetzt bei vierundneunzig Komma eins Prozent taxiert wird.
Von diesen hundertsechsundneunzig Fällen waren auch dreiunddreißig im Alter von fünfundsechzig plus. Das bestätigt halt auch nochmal dieses Bild, dass man grundsätzlich jetzt davon ausgeht, dass diese Impfstoffe.
Nicht so sehr vom Alter abhängig sind, wie gut sie wirken
Das ist ja etwas, was bei Impfstoffen immer so eine Sache ist. Man hat bei anderen Impfstoff andere Krankheiten auch so die Beobachtung gemacht, dass ältere Leute höhere Dosierungen brauchen oder dass es halt einfach grundsätzlich nicht so gut wirkt
hier ist es einfach so, die Immunsysteme reagieren äh mehr oder weniger unabhängig vom Alter gut.
Und das ist natürlich sehr schön und was auch äh sehr schön ist, ist das halt diese Wirksamkeit gegen schwere Verläufe nahezu bei hundert Prozent liegt oder nicht nahezu, sondern bei hundert Prozent liegt, sprich,
Ähm man hat keine schweren Verläufe mehr gesehen bei den Leuten, die geimpft wurden. Das ist wirklich sehr schön und außerdem auch keine nennenswerten Nebenwirkungen. Ich werde auch zu den ganzen Sachen nachher nochmal was sagen.
Das wirft natürlich diese hohe Wirksamkeit wirft natürlich ein gewisses ethisches Problem äh auf äh was weitere Tests
angeht, weil wenn das so wirksam ist, ist es eigentlich kaum noch zu vertreten. Leute mit ähm Placebos zu impfen
Ja, das ist äh sozusagen.
Das Problem, weil das tatsächlich so wie es aussieht lebensrettend,
sein kann und dann sagen Leuten einen Placebo zu geben, die dann sterben. Das ist ja.
Klar, das wird jetzt aber auch dann nicht mehr getan. Also diese Phase drei ist jetzt abgeschlossen und wird dann in eine Phase vier übergehen und da wird dann, glaube ich, äh anders untersucht.
Das bedeutet aber auch, also bei den Impfstoffen hat man's jetzt durch. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass,
andere Impfstoffkandidaten es auch zunehmend schwerer haben werden ethisch.
Solche Tests äh dann zu begründen. Also die, die jetzt noch nicht dabei sind, so kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja gut, aber da laufen die Phasen auch schon.
Sage ich nachher nochmal was äh dazu. Moderner auf jeden Fall hat jetzt diese Zulassung beantragt in USA und EU
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass Mitte Dezember die Zulassung in den USA stattfinden wird. In der EU wird es etwas länger dauern. Da wird sich das gegen Ende des Monats
Anfang nächsten Jahres im Falle von moderner ist glaube ich der Termin bei der EMA, also bei der europäischen Medical äh Autorität weiß ich gerade nicht, was sie abgezogen hat. Äh elfter Januar ist da, glaube ich, so der Stichtag, da wird dann sozusagen
wenn die ganzen vorgelegten Unterlagen und die Ergebnisse dieser Phasen
so richtig medizinisch wissenschaftlich nochmal abgesegnet und wenn sie dann der Meinung sind, ja, passt schon, dann äh gibt es diese Notfallzulassung.
Ja, das passt natürlich jetzt nicht so ganz zu der Ansage mit den Impfzentren oder wie verträgt sich das angeblich, sollte ja schon ab Mitte Dezember hier geimpf.
Werden mit.
Zwanzig Jahr in Berlin sollen pro Tag zwanzigtausend Leute geimpft werden ab Mitte Dezember das war zumindest die Ansage.
Das habe ich auch mal gehört, aber äh ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das stattfinden wird, weil in Deutschland schlicht und ergreifend die Zulassung abgewartet wird. Und diese Zulassung wird frühestens bei dem biontech äh Impfstoff am neunundzwanzigsten Dezember stattfinden.
Was aber getan wird, ist, dass diese Impfzentren aufgesetzt werden, das ist ja jetzt auch erstmal eine Herkulesaufgabe, all diese ganzen Orte, die Distribution zu regeln, et cetera, also der Prozess ist schon in vollem Gange.
Trotzdem wartet man eben die Zulassung ab. Vorangeschritten ist natürlich äh United Kingdom, denn
sowohl der Moderne als auch der Biontech-Impfschoff sind dort jetzt schon zugelassen worden oder bezieht sich das nur auf die Moderne, wenn man jetzt grade nicht ganz so sicher. Ähm auf jeden Fall äh
ist es durchaus möglich für ein Land in der EU den normalen Zulassungsprozess der europäischen Behörde auch abzukürzen.
Das ist vorgesehen im Gesetz. Wenn man der Meinung ist, man hätte einen besonderen Grund.
Der besondere Grund, gut kann man natürlich sagen, hier Notlage und wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie was machen und wir sind uns trotzdem schon äh sicher, also es ist einfach.
Vom EU-Recht her möglich. Nur zieht in Europa derzeit
keiner diese Karte eben mit der Ausnahme mit United Kingdom, weil die halt jetzt irgendwie äh gerade Brexit-Drama haben und irgendwelche Erfolge vorweisen wollen und auch schon an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen sind, wie es eben so dieser Art ist, dieser merkwürdigen Regierung
Ja, das wäre jetzt alles ja nur möglich gewesen wegen wegen Brexit. Ist natürlich totaler Unfug ist, weil.
Der Brexit, von dem sie sprechen, findet ja erst am ersten Januar statt. Derzeit ist noch.
Und alle Regeln gelten, also sie hätten denen jetzt nicht zulassen können, wenn die EU Regelungen nicht dort auch eine Ausnahme ermöglicht, nur dass die anderen Länder halt sagen, nee, wir machen jetzt, wir machen das jetzt hier ordentlich,
Und ich kann das auch sehr gut nachvollziehen, weil man will halt in der öffentlichen Darstellung,
sich überhaupt nicht in diese Bredouille bringen, dass gesagt wird, so ja, ihr habt das ja jetzt vorschnell gemacht und ihr habt ja diesen Prozess, den ihr die ganze Zeit lobt, überhaupt nicht
voll abgeschlossen,
da es am Ende glaube ich auch nicht so den Riesenunterschied macht, ob man jetzt noch eine Woche früher oder später anfängt, zumal er jetzt irgendwie mit Weihnachten sowieso noch ein paar Untiefen mit reinkommen. Läuft's halt so.
Man kann einfach davon ausgehen, im Januar geht's los. Im Januar wird in Deutschland und sicherlich auch in vielen anderen Ländern in Europa geimpft, was das Zeug hält.
Frage ist halt nur, wie viel Impfdosen kann man halt überhaupt bekommen, wie viel Impfdosen kann man überhaupt schnell und das Volk bringen und wie kommt man denn die Leute rein et cetera PP.
Ja, dann gab's aber noch ein Problem und zwar hat äh Björn Tech und Faiser haben Probleme mit der Produktion gehabt.
Es gab ja Aussagen schon vor einiger Zeit.
Welche Mengen an Impfstoffen und Impfstoffdosierungen so bereitgestellt werden können.
Und man war der Meinung, man könnte halt in zwanzig zwanzig bereits einhundert Millionen dieser Impfstoffdosierung.
Ausliefern.
Allerdings hatten sie wohl Probleme mit der Qualität von diversen Ausgangsstoffen. Muss man sich ja jetzt auch mal klar machen, ne. Also man hat hier ein.
Komplett neuen Prozess, also diese MRNA, der ist,
okay, ich muss werde auch nachher gleich nochmal was zu sagen, aber so richtig neu ist er nicht, aber so Lard Skale ist das so noch nie ausgerollt worden. Und natürlich sind für diese Impfstoffe auch
diverse Grundmaterialien
erforderlich und auch die müssen natürlich in der brauchbaren Qualität in Mengen zeitgerecht bereitgestellt werden können.
Da hat's wohl Probleme gegeben und deswegen meinen sie, dass sie jetzt das äh auf die Hälfte runter.
Kürzen müssen. Also es wird erstmal in zwanzig zwanzig von Biontech zumindest nur fünfzig Millionen Dosierungen geben. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, bedeutet, dass das Deutschland am Ende davon ungefähr sieben Millionen Ankommen werden.
Also in der Auslieferung zwanzig zwanzig, sodass eben dann im Januar quasi damit gestartet werden kann.
Aber es wird wird natürlich am laufenden Mitarbeiter produziert. Also die Produktion läuft halt jetzt richtig an und wie viel am Ende jetzt wirklich.
Produziert werden kann, wird man sehen, aber äh ja, findet, findet jetzt statt.
Da habe ich noch einen Nachtrag und zwar gibt's ja jetzt auch noch diesen,
anderen Impfstoff aus England, von der Universität Ochsford, der zusammen mit der Firma Astra Ceneca verhergestellt wird und vertrieben wird.
Auch da gab's ja ganz gute Ergebnisse, also wir hatten
berichtet hier letzte Woche, dass äh bei den Ergebnissen so zwei Zahlen bei rauskamen, bei den Tests in Brasilien, die sie durchgeführt haben, hatten sie wohl eine Wirksamkeit von zweiundsechzig Prozent.
Was jetzt erstmal wenigt im Vergleich zu den vierundneunzig Prozent des MRNA Impfstoffs ist allerdings für einen Impfstoff an sich immer noch ein sehr guter Wert.
Dann gab's noch diese zweite Zahl bei den Tests in UK, wo halt zweiundneunzig Prozent Wirksamkeit hergestellt wurde.
Weil man dort eine andere Dosierung gemacht hat. Die erste Dosierung war nämlich dann nur halb so stark.
Und er ist der zweite Shot war dann eben eine volle Dosis.
Es hat sich ja herausgestellt, dass man damit komischerweise bessere Ergebnisse erzielt. Ich hatte das so dargestellt und so stellte es sich auch insgesamt dar.
Dass äh dass das quasi so ein technischer Unfall war. Ähm stellt sich raus, ist nicht so, der Chef von Astra Zinnecker hat gesagt, nee, das äh,
das Problem war einfach die Verfügbarkeit der Materialien, sie hatten einfach nicht genug Dosierungen, wollten aber äh entsprechend viele Leute behandeln, um da auf ihre Zahlen zu kommen und haben dann einfach entschieden, na gut, dann machen wir es hier einfach mal mit der halben Dosierung
im ersten Schott, damit das irgendwie noch passt und.
Das hat dann eben dieses Ergebnis gebracht. Da der ganze Impfstoffphase drei, Testprozess bei Astracenica in den USA ohnehin angehalten werden musste. Da sollte halt auch nochmal kräftig geprüft werden.
Weil es eine Komplikation gab, ich weiß nicht genau was da ist und jemand ist hat Komplikationen gehabt das ist ein ganz normaler Vorgang in so 'ner Impfstoffprozedur.
Wenn's zu solchen Komplikationen gibt, dann wird erstmal.
Keine weitere Impfung mehr verabreicht und man untersucht das, um festzustellen, was war denn jetzt der Grund und dabei ist wohl festgestellt worden, dass dass das sozusagen nichts.
Mit dem Impfstoff zu tun hat, was er genau vorgefallen ist, kann ich, kann ich dir nicht sagen, weiß auch gar nicht, ob das so im Detail berichtet worden ist, aber da wird dann irgendwas anderes vorgelegen haben. Also.
Leute haben ja auch noch andere medizinische äh Probleme als nur Kovit
und ja, deswegen wird's da jetzt bald weitergehen und die werden dann halt in den USA auch mit dieser Methode, wie sie das in UK gemacht haben, also halbe Dosis, ganze Dosis, das testen, sodass da relativ zügig
auch neue Erkenntnisse gewonnen werden dürften. Ja,
Der Vorteil von diesem Impfstoff aus Oxford ist ja, dass hier auch
die Phase drei etwas umfangreicher durchgeführt wird. Dort ist ja nicht nur geimpft worden und danach wurde geschaut, wie viel Fälle gab es von von Krankheit
man hat dann eben diese Leute auch regelmäßig getestet, die geimpft worden sind, sodass man eben auch die asymptomatischen.
Infektionen feststellen konnte, die man ja sonst nicht findet, weil wenn jemand keine keine keine Krankheitserscheinung hat von dem Virus, aber trotzdem infiziert wurde, dann fällt das halt nicht auf und das ist so eine Information, die bei diesen
anderen beiden bei Bio-Techniken, bei moderner halt noch so ein bisschen unklar sind,
auch wenn's relativ starke Indikationen gibt, dass es eigentlich genauso wirkt. Ähm hier weiß man, dass dann aber auf jeden Fall.
Und ja und überhaupt ist der Impfstoff insofern einfach noch ganz wertvoll, als dass er eben mit einer niedrigeren,
Lagertemperatur auskommen, wesentlich die ganze Zeit im Kühlschrank gehalten werden kann. Das ist halt ein bewährtes Konzept, weil es sich hier um einen sogenannten,
Viktor im Stoff handelt, das heißt hier hat man halt so äh Adenoviren genommen, so Erkältungsviren, wie sie bei Schimpansen auftreten, die halt eigentlich Menschen sowieso nichts äh anrichten
die werden dann halt genetisch modifiziert, sodass sie sich auch nicht weiter verbreiten können. Also dieser Replikationsmechanismus wird ausgeschaltet
Und zusätzlich wird dann eben noch der Soo verändert, dass er eben.
Trotzdem diese Protein Projekt äh Produktion anregt in den menschlichen Zellen, aber dann wird halt eben dieses Bike-Protein vom Ronabyros erzeugt, sodass eben das Immunsystem dagegen anschlagen kann.
Also mein Eindruck ist.
Am Ende wird dieser Wirkstoff genauso effektiv sein und wird auch äh genauso gut produziert werden können und vor allem noch in in existierenden
Anlagen in großen Mengen, sodass wir also hier einen weiteren Beitrag haben, noch weitere Impfstoffe zu bekommen in baldiger Zeit.
Äh gute Überleitung, was ist eigentlich mit Sputnik äh fünf oder V, weiß nicht, ob's V oder fünf ist, äh auf jeden Fall der sagenumwobene russische Virus, da hat ja Russland schon vor einiger Zeit gesagt, so, ja hier
Viros zugelassen. Wir fangen mal an hier mit dem Impfen. Das haben sie halt gemacht, nachdem sie ihre Phase zwei,
abgeschlossen haben, ja? Phase zwei ist ja also Phase eins ist so, man äh findet erstmal raus, wie will man jetzt eigentlich den
den Impfstoff wirklich bauen, also was nimmt man für eine konkrete Zusammensetzung und das findet alles im Labor statt und wenn man sich dann eben auf etwas geeinigt hat, wie man ihn bauen will, dann finden erstmal erste kontrollierte klinische Tests statt. Und danach
geht man dann eben in diesen Phase drei. Also das eben wirklich sehr viele Leute äh infiziert
geimpft werden und und dann schaut man halt, was äh das Ergebnis ist und erst danach kann man halt sagen, okay, alles klar, funktioniert auch so in dem Maße, wie wir es haben wollen. Sicherheit ist äh gegeben. Da gab's relativ viel Kritik, die sicherlich berechtigt ist,
technisch wiederum ist das äh ist dieser,
Impfstoff aus Russland wohl genauso wie dieser Ochsfordimpfstoff. Also der basiert auf demselben Prinzip und äh auch hier.
Gab es jetzt einen Zwischenbericht der Phase drei, also es ist nicht so, dass wir dann auch aufgehört haben, sondern wir haben natürlich trotzdem ihre Phase drei gemacht, auch wenn sie schon behauptet haben, sie hätten jetzt einen, das war dann wahrscheinlich dann doch eher erstmal so für die Public Relations, um irgendwie gut dazustehen und cool rüberzukommen
Ähm uns stellt sich raus, also Zwischenbericht achtzehntausend Probanden, auch hier wiederum
Verabreichung von zwei Dosen im Abstand von drei Wochen und hier gibt es auch eine Wirksamkeit von einundneunzig Komma vier Prozent.
Ähm jeweils gemessen eine Woche nach der zweiten Dosis, also das äh sieht auch ganz gut aus, dass auch dieser Impfstoff in die Welt kann und funktioniert und.
Dann auch so eine richtige Zulassung bekommt, den man auch vertrauen kann. Hier ist eine Markteinführung auch am ersten Januar einundzwanzig geplant.
Also sieht an sich ganz gut aus. So, also das ist einfach es gibt jetzt schon vier Impfstoffe
wir haben hier immer noch Kurwag in Deutschland, die auch, glaube ich, in ihrer Phase drei sind, aber noch kein Zwischenbericht haben, die ein paar Wochen hinterher hängen. Äh viele andere,
Impfstoffprojekte sind noch am Laufen, eine hohe, zweistellige Zahl, glaube ich, weltweit, sodass davon auszugehen ist, dass die Gesamtverfügbarkeitssituation sich noch deutlich entspannen wird
Aber nur, wenn man jetzt auch schon mit den jetzt zugelassenen oder fast zugelassenen Impfstoffen, deren Wirksamkeiten und deren äh Produktionsmengen
sich das alles anschaut. Naja gibt's gibt's Anlass zur Hoffnung, dass das Problem im Laufe von zwanzig einundzwanzig dann doch.
Rechts signifikant zurückgedrängt werden kann.
Wen das alles mal genauer interessiert. Ich meine, es ist jetzt so viel Wissen und ich rede jetzt hier auch irgendwie so neu mal klug daher, dabei ist also äh.
Biologie und Medizin ist nun wirklich überhaupt nicht meine Stärke, ne? Aber man kann sich ja an alles so ein bisschen reinnürden. Es gibt einen schönen Vortrag.
Der auf YouTube zu finden ist, der ist relativ neu, sehr aktuell,
von Florian Krammer, ein österreichischer Birologe und Impfschoffforscher, der derzeit in New York an der Universität arbeitet
Und das ist wirklich meine Empfehlung. Wer eine anderthalb Stunde Zeit hat, sollte sich das mal anschauen,
Das ist wirklich eine sehr gute Übersicht
über die Funktionsweise sowohl des Virus als auch der einzelnen Impfstoff äh Techniken, also
sowohl halt jetzt hier diese MRNA Impfstoffe als auch eben diese Vektorimpfstoffe als auch andere traditionelle Impfstoff äh Verfahren
werden dort genau erläutert
schön Schritt für Schritt, sodass man einen Überblick bekommt, aha, okay, darin unterscheiden die sich, das sind so die Herstellungsmethoden et cetera PP.
Und ja ich hab mir den mal in Ruhe angeschaut und mal abgesehen davon dass er eben erklärt wie das an sich funktioniert gibt er auch nochmal so seine eigene,
Bewertungen und Einschätzung ab, wie denn jetzt mit diesen neuen Impfstoffen, was ist denn da sozusagen zu erwarten ist.
Und er stellt auch äh fest und das ist dann sozusagen auch im Rahmen seines Vortrags auch gut nachvollziehbar, dass einfach diese Wirkstoffe, die jetzt am Start sind, also die Impfstoffe, die jetzt am Start sind.
Eine sehr hohe Sicherheit bieten, dass er also der Meinung ist, dass das einfach.
Für das, was man so bisher im Impfbereich gesehen hat, einfach eine eine extrem hohe Sicherheit, also also kaum nennenswerte.
Komplikationen oder so, die die in irgendeiner Form über das, was man erwarten könnte, hinausgehen,
dann auch schon jetzt oft erwähnt, eine extrem hohe Wirksamkeit eben auch bei Hochresukogruppen hat.
Weist aber dann auch noch darauf hin, dass gerade diese MRNA Impfstoffe auch dafür bekannt sind, eine.
Hohe Reaktorgenität zu haben. Man lernt ja hier jeden Tag auch einen neuen Fachbegriff.
Was ist die Reaktorgenität, die Reaktorgenität ist sozusagen die unmittelbare Auswirkung des Impfens selber
Also da werden ja Stoffe in deinen Körper eingebracht mit dem Ziel, dass die, dass das Immunsystem anschlagen soll. Das ist ja der Sinn dieser ganzen Geschichte und das tut es ja dann auch
Das heißt, wenn man dann geimpft wird, geht das Immunsystem in Alarmmodus und das bemerkt man dann und das von daher ist damit zu rechnen
dass man also besonders bei den MRNA-Impfstoffen, gerade weil sie so effizient sind, eine hohe Reaktion bekommt und das also mit Kopfschmerzen zu rechnen ist, Schmerzen an der Einstichstelle, Muskelschmerzen und so weiter. Aber dass das dann eben
auch in der Regel nach vierundzwanzig, spätestens nach achtundvierzig Stunden dann aber auch weg ist, ne. Das gilt wohl besonders für die zweite Impfung.
Und gerade weil das so ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass trotz dieser Zulassung, die diese Impfstoffe jetzt bekommen oder zumindest.
Oder vielleicht eben erstmal durch diese Notfallzulassung diese Impfstoffe bekommen man diese Impfstoffe an Kinder und Jugendliche erstmal nicht geben wird.
Weil Kinder einfach auf diese Schmerzen stärker reagieren. Nicht weil's ihnen zwangsläufig deswegen schlechter geht oder sie davon mehr zu befürchten haben, aber.
Ich meine, wenn du an uns sagt, hier Impfstoff und so weiter, die geht's jetzt mal zwei Tage schlecht.
Kannst du das irgendwie einpreisen, aber weißt du, ah ja okay, mir tut jetzt alles weh ein bisschen Fieber, dann weißt du, dann dann ist das so im Rahmen deines Erfahrungshorizontes,
abspeicherbar. Dann kommst du irgendwie klar und das das kriegst du mental irgendwie äh geregelt. Für Kinder und Jugendliche.
Die diese Erlebnisse.
So noch nicht gehabt haben und nicht so einordnen können, ist das natürlich ein ganz anderes Empfinden. Und deswegen geht er davon aus, dass man jetzt erstmal anfängt, Erwachsene zu impfen.
Und wenn dann weitere Erkenntnisse gewonnen sind über die Verfügbarkeit und äh die Verträglichkeit dieser Impfstoffe
dann kann es sein, dass man eben entweder diese Impfschoff oder andere, die vielleicht nicht so hohe Reaktorgenität haben, äh dann eben auch,
Kinder gibt. Das ist ja auch insofern jetzt,
da ja nun Kinder auch so absolut unterdurchschnittlich betroffen sind von äh diesem wie großen Auswirkungen des Virus.
Ist es natürlich auch erstmal nicht so ein Problem, ne.
Ja, weiterhin im Vortrag sagt er dann noch, dass also er erzählt es auch sehr schön an diesem Vortrag, also es ist jetzt nicht so eine Werbeveranstaltung, sondern er sagt einfach so, ja, das sind hier so die Fakten, ne? Deswegen äh.
Zeigte eben auch gerade diesen Aspekt Reaktorgenität äh nochmal deutlich auf und äh distet überhaupt sozusagen Dinge auf die man jetzt zu achten hat. Also worauf sollte man jetzt sein Augenmerk,
richten in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten,
Er meint, Produktion könnte halt noch problematisch werden, das hatte ich ja eben schon erwähnt, ne. Man sieht äh Pfeiser bei und Materialien, Verfügbarkeit, et cetera. Das ist also noch nicht gesagt, dass das jetzt wirklich so gut laufen wird, wie äh dass derzeit
vermutet wird oder zumindest gehofft wird und man sollte sich auch darüber im Klaren sein eine gute Immunantwort.
Findet, meist erst zwei Wochen nach der zweiten Info statt.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt in so einen Impfprozess reingeht und seine erste Impfung bekommt, dann ist je nach Wirkstoff vergehen ja nochmal drei oder vier Wochen.
Bis man seine zweite Impfung bekommt und da muss man nochmal zwei Wochen draufrechnen. Also mit anderen Worten, wenn jemand geimpft wird.
Dann ist das Thema vermutlich frühestens nach sechs Wochen gegessen.
Man kann sich jetzt nicht anpieksen lassen und dann ist äh ist man sofort äh geschützt.
Wobei sicherlich eine eine Teilschutzwirkung schon sich innerhalb von wenigen Tagen eigentlich entwickeln müsste.
Ja, da entwickelt sich irgendwas, aber das ist halt auch wirklich greift und das ist auch stark genug ist. Das Ding ist, du kannst ja, da komme ich auch gleich nochmal drauf zu, äh eine Infektion.
Findet ja nicht, es gibt ja nicht so einen einzigen Ort, wo die jetzt Infektion ist und da stehen dann die Torwächter und dann wird das verhindert, ja? Und die sind nur so mehr oder weniger stark, sondern,
Man muss sich darüber im Klaren werden, gerade des Saas, Konamiros kann ja an den verschiedensten Stellen,
angreifen und tut das auch sowohl in der Lunge als eben auch im Rachen, in den, in den Atemwegen, an allen allen Stellen. Und selbst eine voll ausgeprägte Immunantwort muss sich ja auch erstmal im Körper verteilen.
Und liegt dann vor allem halt so,
Blut vor und ist nicht zwangsläufig da, besonders stark, wo das Virus als erstes angreift.
Es wird dann zwar verhindert werden, dass es quasi auf den Rest des Körpers übergreift, aber das heißt auch nicht
unbedingt, dass es nicht erstmal sich irgendwo
festmachen kann, ja? Also die Piraten landen am Strand, aber sie können halt nicht ins Inselinnere vordringen, so ohne Weiteres, aber sie hängen halt trotzdem erstmal am Strand rum
und während also die Impfstoffe sehr gut vor Krankheit schützen, ist es durchaus,
Bar, dass also eine Infektion zumindest in den oberen Atemwegen, also Nase und so weiter äh immer noch möglich ist und es ist theoretisch halt auch,
dass eben dadurch, dass das ja auch so schnell geht beim Corona Virus, dass auch eine Weitergabe des Virus noch möglich ist.
Ja, dass dieser Replikationsprozess zumindest in Teilen deines Körpers einsetzt. Du wirst dann zwar keine Krankheit entwickeln.
Weil das dann eben entsprechend bekämpft wird, aber man kann eben noch nicht ausschließen, dass man nicht zumindest in einem gewissen Rahmen noch äh.
Infektiös sein kann,
weiß man nicht, ist etwas, was man anschauen muss. Es ist eine besonders problematisch zum Beispiel bei Krankenhauspersonal, ja, die halt jetzt einen permanenten äh Kontakt sind und er meint
was halt auch noch ähm unterwegs ist, sind sogenannte nasale Impfstoffe, die sind aber jetzt noch nicht so weit, aber so Na,
was sozusagen auch unmittelbar in diesem äh Rachenoberen Atemwegen äh sich festsetzt
Das könnte sozusagen in der Zukunft es in in den nächsten Monaten nochmal zusätzlich dazu kommen und weitere
Infektionsherde eindämmen. Aber die sind noch nicht.
'ne Art mehr oder weniger sofort temporäre sofortimonisierung der Nase oder so.
Ja, nicht unbedingt sofort, aber äh.
Äh Wirkstoffe, die halt speziell eben sich dann auch in diesen Zellen dann äh in diesen Bereichen des Körpers festsetzen. Kann ich dir das
gesagt, nicht so gut erklären, wie das funktioniert, da liegt auch nicht so der Fokus drauf, aber er hat halt im explizitsten Punkt nochmal herausgestellt, dass also auch
dieser Impfstoff, der uns zwar jetzt, sagen wir mal, das Hauptproblem abnimmt, nämlich, wir wollen ja nicht krank werden. Wir hätten ja mit der Infektion kein Problem, wenn es keine äh Konsequenzen für uns hätte. Also die Krankheiten und damit die Todesfälle und die schweren Verläufe und die langfristigen äh Schäden, die diese Virus hervorrufen kann.
Die werden durch die aktuellen Nimpstoffe vermutlich schon sehr gut bekämpft werden. Die Infektion allerdings.
Kann sein, muss nicht sein, kann sein, dass das sozusagen noch weitere, also es ist entweder eine extrem hohe.
Verbreitung des Impfstoffes erfordert, bis sich das totläuft.
Oder dass es eben noch zusätzlich weitere äh Impfstoffe benötigt, um das so komplett in den Griff zu bekommen, äh wie zum Beispiel eben diese Nasensprays, die noch in Entwicklung sind.
Was auch noch worauf nochmal drauf hinweist ist, Impfstoffe, die diese Phase drei abgeschlossen haben und dann zugelassen werden.
Die hören nicht auf, beobachtet zu werden, sondern es gibt immer auch noch eine Phase vier. Und das ist dann eben etwas, was so im Laufe,
zwanzig einundzwanzig sich äh äh zeigen wird und.
Dann wird man eben auch genauere Erkenntnisse darüber entwickeln können. Hm wie lange hält denn dieser Schutz.
Seine Einschätzung ist, es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass der Schutz jahrelang anhält.
Das leitet er auch her und äh begründet es äh mit dem, was er dort vorträgt, aber eben auch aus seiner eigenen Einschätzung heraus.
Heißt nicht, dass es nicht irgendwann auch nochmal eine Auffrischungsimpfung geben könnte, ja, dass die möglicherweise notwendig ist, aber.
Dafür ist es halt einfach alles noch zu jung. Also ich meine, man man kann nicht über einen einen jahrelangen Schutz irgendwas erzählen, wenn man das nicht jahrelang beobachtet hat. Nur die die Daten, den man derzeit hat, die legen einfach nah
dass ich das sehr lange halten könnte in den Körper. Ja, also er hat da selber ein sehr großes Vertrauen.
In die Wissenschaft hat auch dann zum Schluss auch nochmal gesagt, er hat auch selber an dieser Pfeiser Studie teilgenommen, also er hat quasi diesen Björn-Tech ähm an dieser äh Phase drei teilgenommen. Er sagt, er weiß zwar nicht, ob er
Placebo ist oder nicht, was er damit nur sagen möchte ist, er hatte überhaupt gar kein.
Überhaupt gar keine Bedenken gehabt, speziell, was diese MRNA äh Impfstoffe betrifft, weil auch diese Aussage, die immer im Raum ist,
Na ja, das ist ja ganz neu und das ist ja noch anpufen. Ja, das stimmt insofern, als dass es halt keine MRNA ähm Impfstoffe gibt.
Die die Phase drei abgeschlossen haben an Menschen und schon in weiter Zirkulation sind. Das ist richtig. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so,
Das MRNA-Impfstoffe was komplett neues wären und er hat dann so eine Liste äh auch noch gezeigt. Seit wann das alles ist schon äh entwickelt wird und im Rna-Impfstoffe sind in der Entwicklung seit zwanzig dreizehn.
Das ist also etwas und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum das jetzt alles so schnell geht. Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt jemand sich gedacht hat so, ach.
Pandemie, super, können wir uns mal was komplett neues einfallen lassen, sondern es ist in den letzten zehn Jahren die ganze biochemische Forschung,
die biotechnische Entwicklung, Geräte, Prozesse, Materialien, all das ist schon entwickelt worden, weil man wusste
dass das unter Umständen wirklich ein extrem guter Angriffsviktor ist im ganzen Impfbereich. Und das hat sich jetzt alles ausgezahlt und deswegen geht es jetzt auch so schnell. Fütter auch nochmal auf,
sehr schön übersichtlich, warum es jetzt gelungen ist, den Prozess, den normalerweise fünfzehn Jahre dauern kann
so auf zehn Monate runterzudrücken, was im Wesentlichen halt mit dieser ganzen Parallelisierung der Vorgänger und eben dem Abnehmen der finanziellen Risiken zu tun hat
und er sagt halt einfach nur so all seine Kollegen sehen es genauso,
diesen ganzen Impfschoffforscher, Virologenumfeld, die Hamburg gar kein Problem sich mit diesen MRNA Wirkstoffen impfen zu lassen
weil sie das einfach als eine extrem sichere Sache ansehen. Einerseits würden das halt die Ergebnisse jetzt zeigen, andererseits ist es auch rein technisch und das geht aus diesem Vortrag auch nochmal sehr gut hervor,
ist das eine sehr sichere Geschichte, also diese ganzen Ängste mit oh Gott meine DNA kann verändert werden und so weiter, meint er, das ist einfach Unsinn, also es ist einfach klar, medizinisch weiß man, dass das äh das nicht passiert.
Letzten Endes bildet man nur den Prozess ab, wie auch eine,
Zelle solche Proteinproduktion anstößt und bildet es nach und führt eben mit dieser MRNA diesen Boten rein, der halt normalerweise aus dem Zellkern herauskommt, aber das ist halt,
eine Einbahnstraße. Nichts geht in diesen Zellkern rein, nichts verändert irgendeine DNA und äh von daher.
Ja eine sehr positive Einschätzung der Situation.
Kann im Prinzip sagen,
glaube ich, wenn man die Zelle jetzt als Proteinfabrik betrachtet, dann ist sozusagen der die DNA im Zellkern dafür verantwortlich im Wesentlichen diese,
Fabrik aufzubauen und ähm die normale Proteinproduktion, die körpereigene
zu betreiben und,
wenn so ein MRNA Wirkstoff kommt, dann ist das so wie wenn irgendwie keine Ahnung jemand in die Fabrik kommt und erstmal ein Teil der Maschinerie
für seine eigenen Zwecke benutzt, solange lang diese RNA, diese, diese.
Pläne, dann dann da sind, äh, werden dann eben diese Stellen die eigenen Zellen quasi die Virusproteine
her, aber äh diese Messenger RNA braucht sich dann halt irgendwann auch auf und wenn die halt nicht mehr da sind, hören die Zellen auch auf. Äh.
Diese ähm.
Der baut sich von alleine ab.
Und diese Emmernah kann an sich nicht dies die ist ja auch so instabil deswegen muss der auch so stark gekühlt werden, weißt du? Das sind ja auch so äh Gründe, also dieser ganze.
Aufwand, der da getrieben werden muss, hat einfach auch viel damit zu tun, dass sich das eben schnell selbst zersetzt und das ist an der Stelle natürlich auch ein Sicherheitsfaktor.
So und jetzt lass uns mal äh nochmal ein paar andere Erfahrungsberichte abklappern, die ich ganz interessant fand. Und zwar habe ich einen längeren Artikel Nature gelesen, der beschreibt.
Wie ist denn eigentlich so in Island zugegangen ist? Und Island finden wir ja immer interessant, weil also die Insel.
Immer gute Wege gefunden hat, sich irgendwie aus Krisen herauszuarbeiten, dadurch, dass sie so eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft sind und äh man hat das ja gesehen, sowohl in der Finanzkrise.
Also beim Fußball, wenn die was wollen. Da haben die irgendwie eine eine bemerkenswerte Fähigkeit sich irgendwie ähm da zu engagieren und ja bin ich überraschend.
So war's auch im Falle von Corona, ne? Also auch in Island ist das Problem.
März zu einem geworden, ne? Also so über Skitouristen, also es kam wohl auch dann auch alles irgendwie aus äh Österreich, aus Ischke, was weiß ich, also oder.
Südtirol, keine Ahnung und sie mussten sich natürlich damit auseinandersetzen.
Und ja, der Artikel beschreibt sehr schön,
wie das dann so abgelaufen ist und wie Island sich da aufgestellt hat und warum sie dann am Ende auf eine interessante Art und Weise auch äh sehr erfolgreich waren, weil sie haben's einfach mal holistisch angegangen, sage ich mal, also sie sind da wirklich brei,
breitbandig, haben sie dieses dieses Thema beackert? Wie ist es abgelaufen? Also als klar wurde, okay, das Problem besteht.
Gab's ähm schnell die Idee hier ähm beim isländischen Gesundheitsministerium äh hier irgendwie.
Alles zu aktivieren, was Island so am Start hat und unter anderem gibt es eine Firma, die heißt D-Code Genet,
die in Reklavik äh sitzt, die glaube ich äh USA, also eigentlich eine amerikanische Firma ist, aber die halt ein größeres human.
Genetisches Labor unterhält und Forschung unterhält in in Recabik,
Und die haben sich dann eben mit dem Gesundheitsministerium zusammengetan, haben dann gesagt, okay, alles klar, wir äh werden das jetzt mal ganz intensiv verfolgen,
Und nachdem sie dann angefangen haben, selber PCR-Tests zu machen, haben sie dann sofort beschlossen, dass sie da eine entsprechende Datenbank aufbauen und.
Sie haben ernsthaft jede positiv getestete Person im Nachgang weiter verfolgt.
Das heißt, dass sie tatsächlich bei jedem,
der positiv getestet wird. Ich meine, wie läuft das hier in Deutschland? Wenn ich hier positiv getestet wirst, dann kriegst du halt vielleicht mal eine Nachricht von deiner App, von deinem Testzentrum nach ein paar Tagen. Dann weißt du, bist irgendwie positiv und dann
Quarantäne äh oder in Isolation geschickt und dann und dann deine Familie in Quarantäne.
So und dann war's das im Wesentlichen. Danach festigt irgendwie keiner mehr an. Anders war das in Island. In Island haben sie dann tatsächlich von jedem.
Der positiv getestet wurde aus dieser Probe auch das genommen des Virus sequenziert. Jeder.
Und das in die Datenbank.
Abgelegt. Am Ende wurden bisher, also was heißt am Ende, aber bisher wurden fünfundfünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung getestet.
Das bedeutet auch, dass sie von fünfundfünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung, also sind dreihundertachtzigtausend Leute, die da leben. Von fünfundfünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung,
wurde dann eben auch das Virus, was konkret hier die Infektion verursacht hatte,
segnenziert. Und wir wissen, das bedeutet, dass man dann eben auch daraus ableiten kann, welchen Weg das Virus durch die Gesellschaft genommen hat. Wo kommt das her.
Hat sich hier irgendwas äh mutiert et cetera PP. Und mit dieser riesigen Datenbank haben sie dann angefangen, eben darauf zu äh.
Arbeiten und haben natürlich dann auch die ganzen Krankheitsverläufe auch mitgespeichert. Das heißt, sie wussten bei jeder Person auch genau wie ist es verlaufen.
Und können damit jetzt erstmalig richtig genaue Zahlen liefern, weil alle anderen müssen immer schätzen
Das kennen wir ja auch, ne? So dieses Jahr, was haben wir denn jetzt hier wirklich für 'ne Fallsterblichkeit, wie tödlich ist denn das Viros dunkelziffern? Wir haben ja hier über alles mögliche äh diskutiert und äh eigentlich haben wir uns die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen.
Gefühlt wie blinde Kuh, ne? Und äh ja, keine blinde Kuh in Island.
Die Erkenntnisse waren ganz interessant. Erstmal die Hälfte der Infizierten war asymptomatisch. Die Hälfte.
Kinder haben eine geringere Chance auf Krankheit, okay? Gut, das äh wusste man natürlich auch so, ne? Und häufigste Symptome waren Muskelschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, Husten und nicht Fieber.
Also das stellt sich ja auch in zunehmendem Maße heraus, so dass Fieber nicht unbedingt so ein Zeichen jetzt einer Corona Viruserkrankung ist. Also es macht sich also im Wesentlichen über Schmerzen im Kopf und Muskeln und äh eben durch diesen Husten
klar. Ähm die Todesrate in Island liegt bei sieben Personen von hunderttausend.
Bevölkerung also nicht auf auf erkrankte oder das.
Es geht um die Prävention. Also es sind einfach nur sieben von hunderttausend Personen gestorben in äh der Bevölkerung.
Es sind im Moment neunundsiebzig Komma eins zwo pro Million. Ich habe grad auch mal nachgeguckt, also es passt, sind ein paar mehr geworden, aber äh.
Okay.
Extrem gut und liegt auf einer Ebene irgendwie mit Finnland ein bisschen über Norwegen.
Monaco, genauso gut.
Also man kann sagen, sie haben sozusagen alles verhindert, was zu verhindern war. So kurz gesagt. Wie haben sie das jetzt geschafft, ne? In dieser Zeit blieben die Grenzen offen.
Sie haben seit Juni zwanzig, zwanzig Touristen aus fünfundvierzig Ländern reingelassen, ja.
Allerdings mit der Auflage, wenn du ankommst, musst du dich natürlich testen lassen. Es gab einen nationalen Pandemieplan, der schon im Januar beschlossen wurde
mit Isolation, Quarantäne, Contact Tracing das volle Programm und der erste Fall, der halt, also sie haben quasi den Panimieplan im Januar beschlossen,
als noch gar keine Fälle da waren. Als noch hier noch ja China und so Wuhan.
Voll schwierig und dann halt natürlich ein bisschen Italien und so. Island war gleich am Start, hatte den Plan schon am Start und als dann der erste Fall auftrat, das war am achtundzwanzigsten Februar eben über so einen Skitourist,
haben sie sofort angefangen diesen Pandemieplan zu,
aktivieren und ab dem dreizehnten März hat dann eben dieses äh humangenetische Labor Decode angefangen eben dieses Creening auch komplett zu übernehmen,
Das heißt, sie haben auch das Krankenhaus entsprechend entlastet. Also sie haben wirklich sozusagen die Tests komplett übernommen und das gleich in diese Datenbank reinfallen lassen. Und jeder, der auch nur milde Symptome hatte, konnte sich sofort testen lassen.
Alle Ergebnisse waren spätestens in vierundzwanzig Stunden meistens in vier bis sechs Stunden da.
Vier bis sechs Stunden ist wirklich bemerkenswert, weil dieser PCR-Test dauert in etwa so lange.
Also mehr oder weniger haben sie eigentlich ein du gibst eine Probe ab. Der Test fängt sofort an.
Und wenn das Ergebnis feststeht, hast du sofort das Ergebnis. Das ist sozusagen das, was man daraus lesen kann. Also das ist,
Solange laufen die Maschinen da einfach so lange dauert es einfach. Keinerlei Slack vorne oder dahinter haben sie irgendwie schön optimiert bekommen.
In dem Moment, wo du positiv getestet wurdest, musstest du natürlich dann vierzehn Tage Isolation äh eingehen, klar. Ähm das Ganze wurde in so einer
zentralen Datenbank gespeichert und ähm Labor und Krankenhaus hatten halt Zugriff auf diese Daten
Das heißt egal ob du dir ein Krankenhaus äh behandelt wurdest oder nur äh das Labor mal genauer untersuchen wollte, was Sache ist. Alle hatten sofort Zugriff auf diese Daten.
Und alle Leute, die positiv getestet wurden, würden irgendwie regelmäßig äh angerufen
weiß nicht genau, wie regelmäßig, ob das jetzt täglich war oder alle paar Tage und wurden auf bis zu neunzehn Symptome durchgecheckt, also hat immer jemand angerufen, immer gesagt, hast du das, hast, das, hast du das, ja, nein, ja, nein, ja, nein.
Außerdem haben sie die Virusmenge im Labor auch gemessen. Kannst du äh kannst du, glaube ich, aus dem PCR-Test.
Genau bei den meisten ist es so, dass du, du hast ja da diese Phasen von sozusagen Vermehrung, also warm kalt, also diese
die dadurch laufen werden und wenn nach jedem Zyklus wird dann gemessen, wenn's halt, was weiß ich, irgendwie leuchtet äh oder so
wird dann gemessen und dann je nachdem wie viel Zyklen du brauchst bis zu was siehst.
Das heißt, diese Information haben sie quasi nicht weggeworfen, sondern sie haben sie äh quasi mit abgespeichert genommen. Mhm.
Genau und dann haben sie es genommen noch äh ermittelt, also wirklich bei jeder Probe nachgeschaut, was ist es denn jetzt eigentlich ganz genau und haben dann,
allein vom dreizehnten März bis vierten April, also im Zeitraum von knapp einem Monat irgendwie äh neuntausendneunhundertneunzehn.
Menschen äh getestet, davon waren dreizehn Komma drei Prozent.
Positiv und davon halt wiederum dreiundvierzig Prozent ah symptomatisch. Also das ist äh wirklich bemerkenswert.
Äh die haben's also einfach erschlagen, ne? Gibt da auch eine entsprechende Webseite zu äh Kowit Punkt IS, der Starter. Da kann man das dann irgendwie alles.
Auch nachschlagen und es einfach umfassend, ne? Und vor allem dann auch.
Am Ende sehr äh erfolgreich. Gibt auch ähnliche Herangehensweisen gab es auch in Italien, zumindest in Teilen von Italien, Neuseeland auch. Auch da haben sie sich ähm.
Die die Genoma angeschaut und dadurch einfach die ganzen Ausbruchsketten äh auch ermittelt und ähm da hat man unter anderem auch herausgefunden, dass.
Es wohl in Neuseeland nur eine Verletzung des Lokdowns gab, wo sich jemand nicht dran gehalten hat.
Und dass alle da alle folgenden Infektionen auf diesen Fall zurückzuführen waren
Das haben sie quasi durch diese molekulare Epidemiologie, wie sich das nennt, äh herausgefunden, ne? Also nicht irgendwie die Fußjahre ist, was äh verletzt worden und jetzt haben wir erstmal ein Problem, jetzt müssen wir draufhauen, sondern sie konnten danach auch wirklich genau sagen
Diese Verletzung äh des Lokdowns hat zu allen Fällen geführt, die wir danach gesehen haben.
Was äh einfach wirklich eine interessante Erkenntnis ist, ne? Ja und Antikörper haben sie wohl auch äh untersucht.
Und haben dann auch festgestellt, dass auch nach vier Monaten einundneunzig Prozent der infizierten wohl noch sehr hohe Werte hatten.
Dass Antikörper sich hier wohl in zwei Wellen aufgebaut haben. Also es ist so eine erste Welle gibt und dann später nochmal so eine zweite äh Welle ähm und auch das trägt natürlich wieder zu diesem Bild bei, dass eben auch äh,
Stoffe, die ja letzten Endes dasselbe auslösen dann auch äh entsprechend lange ähm noch schützen können.
Gibt dann wohl so eine schnelle Reaktion durch Plasmazellen und dann irgendwie gibt's dann langlebige Zellen, die dann zweite Geschichte macht, ne.
Egal, auf jeden Fall äh die Infection Fatality Rage Show, also wie viele Leute sterben, die sich tatsächlich infiziert haben? Das war ja auch so eine Zahl, die wir hier tausend Mal hin und her diskutiert haben, liegt in Island bei null Komma drei Prozent.
Also drei von tausend, die sich infiziert haben.
Dass äh.
Entdeckt sich ähm ja mit der Rate aus der äh Strick äh Studie von wie ist das Kaff noch? Sorry.
Ähm ja, ist schon eine Weile her gangelt.
Genau, also sie gangelt. Studie lag ja auch bei null Komma drei. Ich.
Äh hatte seinerzeit eher ein bisschen mehr geschätzt so, aber null Komma drei würde.
Im Endeffekt.
Bedeuten, dass wir dann doch deutlich höhere, dunkelziffern haben, als wir gedacht haben.
So, wenn's nur.
Wenn's tatsächlich null Komma drei sind, wobei natürlich äh man jetzt auch gucken muss, ist das ein Wert, äh der hal.
Äh auch auf dieselbe Altersverteilung wie in Deutschland umgerechnet ist. Also ist der sozusagen,
normiert, weil wenn du jetzt mehr Alter hast und dann natürlich dadurch, dass die Infektionszahlen in Island natürlich allgemein
eher gering waren kann sein, dass halt auch weniger alte Betroffenen waren insofern ja denke ich für Island trifft das zu, aber wer halt noch interessant.
Zu sehen wie sich das äh Altes.
Kriegt man unter oben schön auf dieser genannten Web
raus, die ist wirklich ganz interessant, also die unterscheiden da auch zwischen der Institanz mit inländischen Infektionen, also mittlerweile ist da auch ein bisschen hochgegangen, da sind sie gerade bei fünfundvierzig, acht.
Vorhin schon im Vergleich, also noch deutlich unter allen anderen und dann gibt's nochmal eine explizite Insident Borderscreening, also alle Leute, die halt irgendwie angeflogen kommen.
Ich hab grad mal geguckt, also die testen, sie haben ungefähr bisher pro Kopf doppelt so viele Tests gemacht wie in Deutschland so.
Sagen muss, you cay ist auch ziemlich weit oben und Belgien hat auch ziemlich viel getestet. So, aber Island ist da definitiv ja spitzenreiter mit doppelt so viel Tests wie bei uns.
Nur einem Drittel äh so viele Tote pro ja Millionen oder welchen Wert man da auch immer nimmt.
Ja, wer Weihnachten noch Urlaub machen möchte im äh sonnigen Island, der äh muss sich darauf einstellen, wenn man ankommt, äh vierzehn Tage Quarantäne.
Oder alternativ ein Test bei Ankunft und ein zweiter fünf Tage später und dann darfst du auch rein.
Zwanzig Prozent sind nach fünf Tagen noch positiv.
Ja, also das entwickelt sich natürlich alles. Ja, also das das war so Island und Island hat's sehr genau genommen und zeigt auch wieder, wie gut sowas funktionieren kann, wenn man halt, sagen wir mal, ein etwas.
Zusammenhängendes soziales Gesamtgefüge hat, wo solche Entscheidungen natürlich dann auch deutlich einfacher und schneller zu fällen sind. Ähm und natürlich auch,
Klar, Insel, ne? Äh definierten definiertes Rein und raus hat und nicht so wie Deutschland zusammenhängt mit tausend anderen äh.
Ländern, wo sie sowas natürlich sehr viel schwieriger realisieren lässt. Grade mit offenen Grenzen.
Eine zweite wissenschaftliche Untersuchung gibt's auch noch und zwar hatten wir hier gesprochen über die Slowakei.
Ja diese Massenschnelltests gemacht hat, diese Antigentests.
Um einfach ihre ausufernden Infektionszahlen in Griff zu kriegen, was ja auch weitgehend funktioniert hat, auch wenn es jetzt gerade so ein bisschen äh stagniert, aber es war ja ist ja richtig nach oben geschossen und wurde dann,
doch relativ gut wieder eingefangen und hier hat man's einfach mit Schnelltests gemacht. Ähm wie übrigens jetzt auch gerade SU Speak äh in diesen Tagen
Österreich versucht wird, da hat man sich wohl inspirieren lassen von den Ergebnissen in der Slowakei und jetzt gibt's da ein Bericht da drüber, ein Paper, der das mal so.
Genau darstellt, was was sind jetzt eigentlich wirklich getan wurde.
Ausgangslage war das halt extrem hohe Infektionszahlen gab im Land, aber vor allem im Norden des Landes, also an den Grenzen zu Tschechien und Polen.
Und was sie dann gemacht haben ist, sie haben das halt angekündigt.
Eine Woche vor den ersten Tests wurden Kontakt und Bewegungseinschränkung schon gemacht, in welchem Umfang kann ich nicht sagen.
Und dann wurde das Ganze in drei Phasen äh durchgeführt. Zunächst einmal gab's eine Pilotphase.
Wo man wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal den Prozess getestet hat und ne sozusagen bevor man das aufs ganze Land ausrollt, wollte man erstmal sehen, dass man damit klarkommt. Das haben sie nur in vier der Landesteile gemacht. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel es gibt, glaube ich, so zwanzig, dreißig oder sowas.
Und äh das fand sozusagen als erstes statt und dann wenn ich's richtig sehe, eine Woche später,
ging's dann quasi Nation White los, das heißt sie haben es auf die aufs gesamte Land ausgedehnt. Das war die sogenannte Runde eins.
Und dann eine Woche später nochmal eine zweite Runde im Prinzip auch Nation-Weit, allerdings nur bei den Landesteilen, die dann sozusagen noch so eine,
Dir beim ersten Test so eine Prävalenz über vierundfünfzig über fünfundvierzig hat.
Also man hat überall mal reingetestet und bei den besonders stark betroffenen Landesteilen hat man dann eben nochmal einen zweiten Durchlauf gemacht,
Ja und das bedeutet, dass dann also innerhalb dieser zwei Wochen fünf Komma zwei sieben Millionen.
Test durchgeführt wurden und davon, das hat man glaube ich auch schon gesagt, waren ungefähr null Komma neun sechs Prozent.
Positiv, also knapp ein Prozent war, war positiv, also jeder hundertste war positiv,
Und zwar positiv nicht im Sinne von PCR-Test, positiv, sondern eben im Sinne von Antigentest, positiv, also inf
yös, ne? Unter Umständen waren auch sehr viel hätten bei auf dem PCR-Test noch sehr viel mehr äh angeschlagen. Das kann man jetzt irgendwie versuchen hochzurechnen, aber ist ein bisschen müßig
Und äh hier wollte man aber sozusagen eben durch diese Schnelltest oder konnte man durch diesen Schnelltest eben nur Leute, die eben auch eine relativ hohe Viruslast tragen und damit eben auch sehr
infektiös sind herausfiltern, hat das dann eben auch getan. Das heißt, die Leute wurden natürlich dann rausgenommen und Quarantäne für die Haushaltsmitglieder et cetera
Ja und von Runde eins auf Runde zwei hat also dann bei den zum zweiten Mal getesteten ähm.
Landesteilen dann eben die gesamte Privainzuchtundfünfzig Prozent abgenommen und wenn man den Piloten noch mit einschließt äh,
sogar um zweiundachtzig Prozent. Ja und insgesamt gilt das als alles sehr erfolgreich. Ähm diese südlichen Regionen, die ja von vorne herein niedrigere äh Werte hatten
diesen nahezu komplett in dieser Runde zwei gar nicht mehr dabei gewesen. Also da hat sozusagen allein schon dieser Schnelltest.
Die Ergebnisse so geliefert, dass dass es gar nicht mehr nötig war nachzutesten. Ja.
Und jetzt ist Österreich dran und ist gerade dabei. Das geht jetzt irgendwie vom vierten bis zum dreizehnten äh Dezember.
Habe ich mir aber jetzt noch nicht genau angeschaut, was da, was da äh genau gemacht wird.
Ja, ich guck mir grade nochmal die sagen nochmal die Zahlen.
An und welche Entwicklung das genommen hat. Wann genau heißt das noch, wann die die Testrunde durchgeführt wurde.
Pilot fand statt am dreiundzwanzigsten und fünfundzwanzigsten Oktober dann Runde eins einunddreißigster Oktober und erster November und die zweite Runde am siebten und achten November.
Also Höhepunkt.
War am vierten November dort an gemeldeten Zahlen und seit da ging's dann auch runter, also Höhepunkt.
War bei vier sechsundsechzig und sie sind jetzt.
Also es hat im Prinzip die Zahlen halbiert innerhalb von aber drei Wochen etwa.
Kann man sagen, seitdem geht's aber auch nicht mehr weiter runter. Ich meine, was auch irgendwie logisch ist äh so.
Aber es ging auch danach nicht wieder sofort sofort hoch, aber das ist scheint auf jeden Fall eine Methode zu sein, ähm um seine äh Institz zu halbieren in drei Wochen.
Davon sind wir weit entfernt. Also wir haben noch nicht mal eine Reduktion.
Geschafft. Also im Prinzip kann man sagen haben die eigentlich zur selben Zeit losgelegt wie wir. Richtig, Anfang November.
So, der Unterschied ist nur.
Das bei uns die Zahlen seitdem gleich geblieben sind.
Und sie sich bei denen halbiert haben. So kann man das zusammenfassen. Ja.
Ja
Gut, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, kostet natürlich auch was, den Aufwand zu betreiben, logisch, ne, die Testkosten was muss natürlich auch die Verfügbarkeit haben, dieser Tests und es ist jetzt sicherlich nicht unbedingt auf
gesamtdeutschland so anwendbar, aber es wäre zumindest durchaus vorstellbar, dass man eben in den besonders betroffenen Gebieten oder zumindest in den Gebieten, die damals besonders betroffen war, sowas gemacht hätte, ja. Also wenn du zum Beisp,
dir mal Berlin vorgenommen hättest so? Ja das äh hätte wahrscheinlich richtig was gebracht so und das ist natürlich dann auch.
Interessantes Signal so, ne? Es ist etwas, worum was auch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise
wahrgenommen wird. Also sowas könnte ich mir hier halt auch immer noch durchaus vorstellen und wäre jetzt äh vor Weihnachten auch wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige.
Allerdings haben wahrscheinlich jetzt die Slowakei und Österreich die ganzen Tests weggekauft und wir haben im Moment nicht genug davon, um flächendeckend irgendwas zu machen.
Das kann schon sein, aber das weiß ich nicht. Also das äh das ist noch so ein Verfügbarkeit von Schnelltest ist so ein bisschen ein ein fortwährendes äh Mysterium. Dafür gibt's irgendwie keine Zahl.
Gut, können wir vielleicht mal zum Schluss weg von den konkreten Corona-Virus eine Meldung, die du wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen hast und die vielleicht oder vielleicht auch nicht hier eine Rolle spielt.
Haben die mal äh anderes Interessantes Licht auf die Weiterentwicklung wirft, ist.
Das ist ja eine interessante Ankündigung gab äh aus der biotechnischen Forschung.
Nämlich äh sieht es so aus, als ob hier ein Problem gelöst werden kann.
Oder schon wurde,
äh was so die Biologie seit Jahrzehnten beschäftigt, seitdem man eigentlich weiß, wie das so mit der DNA funktioniert und mit den Molekülen und mit den Proteinen will man halt in irgendeiner Form äh,
herausfinden wie denn diese Proteine konkret sich ausbilden auf Basis
Ihrer ihres genetischen Codes ist für uns ja sehr einfach, gehen äh auszulesen, da müssen wir eine ganze Menge dadrüber, dass.
Humane, genommen gilt als entschlüsselt und wir wissen in etwa wie dieser Prozess funktioniert und das zeigt ja auch gerade diese ganze Debatte, um diese Impfstoffe sehr wohl.
Allerdings ist es halt so, dass all diese Proteine, die uns ja, was weiß ich, glaube ich, zu sechzig Prozent ausmachen und die der Motor jeglichen Lebens sind, dass,
dass sie eben in ihrer Funktion erst in dem Moment wirklich so richtig verstanden werden können, wo man sie sich mal ganz genau anschaut. Und so ein Molekül sich genau anzuschauen, ist sehr schwierig,
Da sind auch ein paar interessante Durchbrüche erzielt worden. Unter anderem diese Kryo.
Ähm Mikroskopie äh Technologie, die glaube ich auch vor ein paar Jahren Nobelpreis bekommen hat. Hat da einen großen Beitrag zu geleistet.
Weil man dann eben.
In der Lage war, sich eben die molekulare Strukturen auch wirklich mal zu visualisieren und darüber Aufschlüsse zu erhalten. Okay, was,
Was macht denn dieses Protein eigentlich wirklich, beziehungsweise wie kann man denn mit diesen Proteinen jetzt in irgendeiner Form in Kontakt treten oder im Falle von Viren? Was kann man da eben eigentlich tun? Denn.
DNA, das ist ja erstmal nur so eine Bauvorschrift, aber was dann daraus konkret gebaut wird.
Wusste nicht, wie sich das dann eben räumlich auch wirklich ausbildet. Also man spricht da von dieser Proteinfaltung.
Es ist ja als ich so eine lange.
Kette, die sich dann halt irgendwie umeinander schlingt und durch tausend chemische, physikalische äh Prozesse, die eben sehr viele Möglichkeiten bietet und man hat eben jetzt immer schon versucht, das rauszufinden
das eigentlich wirklich funktioniert. Und es gibt da ein ähm Wettbewerb.
Der sogenannte Caspetbewerb. Kritical Assessment of Tickets vor Protein Structur Production. Also kurz gesagt, eine kritische Prüfung von Techniken zur,
Vorhersage von Proteinstrukturen, also dieser Proteinfaltung, der findet irgendwie alle zwei Jahre statt. Und was die da machen ist, dass sie.
Proteine, die von denen man noch bisher offiziell nicht wusste, wie sie aussehen.
Die aber in irgendwelchen Laboren über gängige Methoden unter anderem diese Kryomikroskopie.
Wo herausgefunden wurde, wie denn diese Struktur ist, von dem aber alle anderen, solange das noch nicht publiziert wurde, nur die DNA kennen.
Also den Bauplan, aber nicht, wie sich das Ding eben tatsächlich faltet. Und dann werden halt diese diese äh genetischen Codes äh den Testteilnehmern gegeben und gesagt, so, ja okay, versuche mal vorauszusagen, wie sich das Ding jetzt.
In der Realität zusammenfaltet oder entfaltet.
Ja zusammenfaltet ihr. Also.
Ja, es faltet sich zusammen, aber es entfaltet sich sozusagen,
Und ja da waren die Ergebnisse in den letzten Jahren wohl na ja so nicht so geil. Ähm, es gibt da so ein,
wert, mit dem das Ganze ähm bewertet wird, der sogenannte Global Distance Test.
Der so ein äh Ergebniswert von null bis hundert liefert und wenn man quasi,
also der letzten Endes die Ähnlichkeit ausdrückt und wenn man in dieser Ähnlichkeit so einen Wert von neunzig erreicht, dann ähm.
Kommt man so in diesen Bereich rein, wo man sagt, besser sind unsere bildgebenden Verfahren derzeit auch nicht, also genauer kann man's nicht bestimmen und man geht dann davon aus, dass man bei, wenn man so einen Wert von neunzig erreicht.
Dass man's dann gefunden hat. Das kann ich nicht genauer erklären, aber so, so wurde das irgendwie dargestellt. Also es ist zumindest identisch zu diesen Messergebnissen, die man aus den ähm.
Laborprozessen heraus hat. Und vor zwei Jahren fand es wohl das äh letzte Mal statt und jetzt auch nochmal und da gab's dann schon einen interessanten Contender, nämlich Google,
Google Alpha, das ist diese KI-Abteilung von,
die auch schon Durchbrüche gebracht hat im Bereich Schach und was am meisten beachtet wurde in den letzten Jahren Go.
Alpha Go ist äh das KI Produkt, was halt in der Lage war so gut zu spielen, dass auch die stärksten Go-Spieler nicht nur geschlagen wurden, sondern danach mit,
äh offenem Mund vor dem Ergebnis dieser Maschine standen, weil Alphago es geschafft hat, mit seinen,
Schienenlearning basierten künstlichen Intelligenzansatz, eine Art und Weise zu entwickeln, wie Go gespielt wird, wie sie so noch nie gesehen wurde. Also es war.
Mhm. Ja, ja.
Go nicht gut
aus, aber das ist ja irgendwie viele schwarz-weiße Steine, Miriaden an Möglichkeiten wie dieses Spiel sich entwickeln kann und man fährt da halt totale Meterstrategie, ne? Das ist das, was sozusagen so einen guten Go-Spieler ausmacht. Man versteht in etwa, wo man hin will und äh jedes Spiel ist anders und zwar nochmal sehr viel auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise anders als
ein Schachspiel immer anders ist und äh von diesen Mittagsstrategien, die halt Alphago am Tag gelegt hat, hat man.
So noch nichts gesehen und alle waren irgendwie total beeindruckt und es war schon klar, dass dieses Google Alpha Projekt da.
Ganz gut dabei ist, dass sie sozusagen ihre Materie äh und ihre Aufgabenstellung gut verstanden haben und in der Lage sind, da äh Lösungen zu liefern. Und jetzt haben sie sich halt mit einem Produkt, das dann eben passenderweise Alpha foldt heißt.
Handelt es sich hier um Alphafold zwei äh an diesem Wettbewerb mit beteiligt und in diesem Jahr haben sie es geschafft äh tatsächlich.
Mehrere aber nicht alle Aufgaben zu lösen und,
kamen wohl so insgesamt in der Summe zu einem Ergebnis von zweiundneunzig Komma vier in diesem Global Distance Test mit anderen Worten, man geht davon aus, dass sie den Code geknackt haben.
Bei schwierigen Proteinen sind sie wohl noch bis zu siebenundachtzig gekommen, was irgendwie auch.
Als sehr bemerkenswert gilt. Wenn man sich so Reaktionen durchliest, gibt's zwar hier und da auch noch ein paar verhaltene Kommentare im Sinne von na ja, ist ja jetzt noch nicht so richtig publiziert, wie es genau funktioniert und das äh wollen wir uns nochmal anschauen
und es wurde auch bemängelt, dass es ja das Alphafuld auch nicht alle Aufgaben, glaube ich, gelöst hat.
Dass das sozusagen muss man nochmal schauen
aber dass die diese gelöst haben, sie halt so gut gelöst haben, wie noch nie jemand zuvor und jetzt sind alle ein bisschen exited und
gehen davon aus, dass das jetzt hier quasi die Basis ist für ein biotechnischen Durchbruch, wie wir ihn so noch nicht gesehen haben in diesem Berei.
Ich hab mir zufällig hab ich mir Alpha folgt gestern angeguckt beziehungsweise 'nen YouTube Video oder einen kurzen, einen kurzen Slide Vortrag darüber, weil
sagt so harte, also dem Paper einen fertiges gibt's noch nicht, aber es ist so einiges schon veröffentlicht worden und
Ich kenne mich ja so ein bisschen äh aus mit ähm ja tiefen, neuronalen Netzen äh und wollte natürlich wissen.
Irgendwie auch, okay, wie machen die das denn jetzt? Weil äh also erstmal.
Ist es eigentlich nicht unbedingt naheliegend, würde man erst was sagen, weil eigentlich ist es jetzt eine, ist es eine Simulation und äh
du kennst vermutlich Folding at Home oder was seit.
Ja, das ist so dieses Tystributed Computing Projekt, was versucht hat, das sozusagen mit.
Genau, das seit zwanzig Jahren, wo man seinen Rechner und seine Grafikkarte bereitstellen kann an Wissenschaftler, äh um eben
dann das Ganze auf, ich sage mal, klassische Weise zu
simulieren und da sind glaube ich bereits hundertvierundvierzig Paper oder so rausgefallen aus foligen at home.
Alleine. Oh, letztlich bei.
Bei dem Ansatz, der da Gefahren äh wird äh trainierst du ein neuronales
Netz. Ähm das heißt, du brauchst Trainingsdaten und eine sehr richtig
erwähnt, also die Trainingsdaten ist das, was man mit allen möglichen Verfahren irgendwie, ich dachte eigentlich, dass wir vor allem Röntgen, Christalographie oder so, aber ja.
Kann auch sein, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Star erwähnt auf jeden Fall ist es ziemlich aufwendig äh so eine die drei D Struktur von so einem Protein.
Experiment zu ermitteln oder zu erfassen und ich glaube, ich habe sowas gehört von das kostet zu dreihunderttausend.
Euro oder Dollar pro Protein? Äh was oder äh zumindest nee, umgekehrt, es waren dreihunderttausend Proteine
die man bisher gerechnet hat, aber es ist es ist teuer, es ist teuer. Es ist nicht so mal eben, also es ist
irgendwie viel, viel billiger äh menschliches Genom zu sequenzieren, als diese drei D Struktur von einem Proteinkost nicht hundert Mal so viel einzelnes Protein da,
dessen 3D-Struktur zu entschlüsseln und die Simulation ist halt.
Deswegen ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil man diese Proteine werden ja äh.
Produziert, indem jetzt die DNA ausgelesen wird und äh dann
Aminosäuren äh einfach ähm ja in
eine Kette von Aminosäuren erstmal produziert wird. Die Kette ist super einfach, das ist Triviala wissen wir, welches welche äh welch
welche Gensequenz jetzt, welche Aminosäure kodiert und wie die dann hintereinander hängen, so das ist sozusagen der triviale Teil, aber was dann wohl passiert ist, dass eben diese Kette bleibt halt nicht.
Ähm einfach eine Kette, sondern die knüllt sich, wenn man will, also Falten ist eigentlich äh schon
ja sehr positiv ausgerüstet. Eigentlich knüllt sich das Ganze zusammen und auch nicht alles auf einmal, sondern je nachdem wie in dieser 3D-Struktur
jetzt welche Proteine da sind, ähm haben die natürlich andere elektrische Felder und,
Jetzt versucht sich natürlich dieses Protein insgesamt so zu knüllen, dass.
Äh möglichst wenig Energie drin gespeichert ist, aber das tut es halt eben nicht auf einmal, sondern ein ein Stück
und auch nicht ja also es passiert halt in vielen Schritten und abhängig davon, was vorher schon da war und und anderen Dingen und.
Es kann halt auch zu Fehlfaltungen kommen. Also bei manchen Proteinen, dass sie sich halt nicht leider auf
verschiedensten Gründen nicht so falten, wie sie sich falten sollten und äh dass es halt auch Ursache dann von ganz vielen Krankheiten, wenn äh du fehlgefaltete Proteine äh hast. Insofern ist das da auch,
und ich hab's mir und wie es jetzt funktioniert, sagen mit mit Alphafold ähm,
es ist auch wenn ein tiefes, neuronales Netz, was spezialisiert ist.
Ja auf äh äh darauf äh.
Das zu tun und was du im Prinzip als Input ähm.
Bekommst sind vermutlich sodings, also im Prinzip hast du dann einen Eingang für äh jede Aminosäure wahrscheinlich oder für Gruppen äh von,
Aminosäuren und äh das wird dann,
quasi als Input reingegeben und dann hast du halt dies gewaltige Netz und am Ende was dabei rausfällt ist.
Einen zwar eigentlich einen 2D Bild, das richtig verstanden habe, wo aber in dem Bild.
Abstände kodiert sind äh von verschiedenen Teilen dieses Proteins. So kann man sich das ungefähr vorstellen. Das heißt, du kriegst so eine Art,
Radarbild, wenn du so so willst von äh diesen ähm von diesem Protein ähm.
Oder ja Röntgenbild oder wie auch immer, wobei äh du dann nicht nur hell oder dunkel hast, sondern die Entfernungen äh ungefähr davon. Weil ich konnte mir nicht so recht vorstellen, wie sie jetzt sagen.
Im Rahmen eines neuronalen Netzes jetzt 3D Strukturen, also drei D Proteinstrukturen da tatsächlich verarbeiten und,
Sie tun's nicht wirklich, sondern es ist quasi so eine Art Zweieinhalb-D-Methode, aber
wenn du diese Entfernungen hast, dann kannst du daraus äh dann recht einfach die drei D Struktur dann mit, ich sag mal herkömmlichen Mitteln äh rekonstruieren, dann hast du sozusagen den Hinweis, okay.
Falte das ungefähr so und dann lässt man halt die richtige Simulation äh drüberlaufen, die halt
die ganzen elektromagnetischen Felder
dann noch berücksichtigt und dann quasi faltet sich das im letzten Schritt dann so zurecht, wie es dann
in der Natur aussieht, aber der Messwert ist wahrscheinlich genau dieser GDT Global Distance Test, keine Ahnung, ob das wie in wie weit das da ähm mit äh zusammenhängt, aber.
Ja, also so äh weit äh habe ich das halt jetzt verstanden, wie sie's machen.
Auf der einen Seite ist es äh durchaus.
Valide, weil du hast dein Trainingsdatenset und während des Trainings stellst du auch einen Teil der Daten zurück, um äh selber auch noch.
Zu testen so um dein dein Verfahren zu optimieren und dann,
nachdem du das getan hast, lässt du es halt auf komplett neue Daten los, die.
Zur Trainingszeit nicht gesehen wurden. Und jetzt ist aber die entscheidende Frage, okay, wie ähnlich sind denn jetzt diese neuen Daten, die du hast äh zu den Trainings,
Daten und inwieweit hast du jetzt auch einen Repräsentatives äh repräsentativen Satz an Trainingsdaten äh tatsächlich. Und das ist mir halt halt unklar,
inwieweit das jetzt tatsächlich dann
verallgemeinerbar ist, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie diesen Wettbewerb schon so konzipiert haben, dass das Ergebnis aussagekräftig ist und,
Es wird in der Community, also manche reden von einem Alex Net Moment.
Das war damals als alle Alex nett und Imagenet bei der Builder klassifizierung
plötzlich so einen unglaublichen Sprung gemacht haben, als man äh das mit Dieb,
Learning auf einmal versucht hat, was quasi dieses.
Dieses einzelne Ding hat dann tatsächlich die jetzt die dritte KI Welle los,
getreten und ja.
Als als in der Lage waren dann in allen YouTube-Videos die Katzen zu finden und.
Genau, das war ja Katzenfinden und Katzen von Hunden unterscheiden und äh solche Dinge, was man vorher.
Viel, viel schlechter machen wollen und plötzlich hatte man auch innerhalb von.
Von einem Jahr und dann auch noch in den Folgejahren unglaubliche Sprünge, die es halt in den letzten dreißig Jahren nicht gab bei der Bilderklassifizierung oder Erkennung und,
möglicherweise ist jetzt sagen dieser Schritt jetzt hier mit Alphafold ja auch so ein.
Alex nit Moment, dass wenn sich das jetzt bestätigt und weiterhält, kam er plötzlich ja in relativ kurzer Zeit sehr, sehr viele Proteine durchsimulieren oder oder,
eine eine Faltung äh dieser Proteine aus den Genen. Also letztlich geht es darum, du hast ein Stück DNA.
Kannst dann vorher sagen die 3D Struktur von dem Protein was,
aus dieser DNA entsteht und aus dieser 3D-Struktur dann wiederum kannst du Schlüsse auf die Funktion dieses Proteins ziehen. Da gibt es dann so.
Ecken und Lücken und.
Wo dann andere Moleküle reinpassen. So, das ist dann aber Schritt zwei, das hat dann jetzt nichts mehr mit Alphaful zu tun, aber das ist dann wieder der Ausgangspunkt. Dafür äh dass
man äh dann ja genetischen Erkrankungen oder Stoffwechselerkrankungen überhaupt.
Generell ja alle möglichen biologischen Prozesse, die im Körper stattfinden und ganz viele Krankheiten von Krebs über Alzheimer, über,
alles wo irgendwo Gene mit dran beteiligt sind, Hunthintons, die sies ja.
Medikamentendesign.
Oder halt Impfstoffentwicklung, ne? Genau, darum deswegen habe ich das ja hier überhaupt äh noch in die Sendung getragen. Ähm nicht, weil das jetzt an unmittelbarer Auswirkung hat, aber weil das halt etwas ist, was äh potenziell auch nochmal zeigt
schnell sich gerade dieser Bereich der Wissenschaft weiterentwickelt, ja? Also wir haben jetzt mit diesen MRNA Impfstoffen so einen gewaltigen Sprung gemacht ähm auch prozessual
wie kann man das beschleunigen, wenn genug Geld da ist, wenn genug Interesse da ist, äh gezeigt, dass es hier schnell vorangehen kann und mit so einem Werkzeug.
Ähm vielleicht mit genau diesem Werkzeug, aber vielleicht sagen wir mal auch erst mit den Werkzeugen, die auf den Schultern dieses Werkzeuges jetzt äh
äh residieren. Kann man ja dann sagen wir haben auch sehr schnell, was weiß ich jetzt
irgendwie ein Virus und ein anderes Protein kommt auf einmal zum Einsatz, man will da halt dann einen Schnelltest für entwickeln, dann muss man wissen, wie sieht das aus, ne? Dieser Anti-Gentest, den wir jetzt auch hier mehrfach besprochen haben
Als er deshalb an die Gentest, weil sie sich quasi an bestimmt teile dieses Proteins, nämlich an der Stelle, wo es eben auch
poniert ist, also da wo es quasi außen ist und nicht zusammengefaltet ist, äh äh andockt,
denn diese Teile äh erkennt und dazu muss man halt wissen, wie dieses Protein aussieht und wenn man das halt allein schon aus der Genstruktur heraus lesen kann,
äh wie sich das Ding letzten Endes darstellt
dann sind natürlich auch die äh Folgeschritte äh an der Stelle unter Umständen noch schneller zu machen. Also es ist wirklich faszinierend, was was ein in dem Bereich Biotechnologie grade äh abgeht.
Mir ja, eben mir fällt da gerade so ein bisschen so eine Parallele ein. Erinnerst du dich? Ja, mit Sicherheit erinnerst du dich an, sagen die erste.
Internetblase, die dot com Blase um das Jahr zweitausend, wo alle irgendwie davon ausgehen, okay, jetzt das Internet, wir werden alle im Internet einkaufen und irgendwie, das wird.
Alles groß werden.
War das nicht schon fünfundneun.
Ja das ging so ne, aber das ging so um zweitausend ging's halt so richtig gings halt so richtig ab.
In der Öffentlichkeit so richtig los, ja, ja.
Alles wird Internet so. Dann platzte die Bubble und dann ähm meisten Leute erstmal darüber gelacht.
Aber dann jetzt zwanzig Jahre später äh ist fast alles.
Eingetreten, was man damals vielleicht ein bisschen verfrüht angenommen hat,
und seit auch fast zwanzig Jahren oder vielleicht schon länger höre ich so wie wir ja demnächst maßgeschneiderte,
Medikamente abhängig von jetzt ja deinem Genom und deiner spezifischen Erkrankung,
haben werden und ich habe das Gefühl, dass dass tatsächlich nicht mehr allzu weit ist, ich meine, es gi
es in bestimmten Bereichen, aber ich stelle mir halt vor und das gibt es halt noch nicht, dass ich halt zum Arzt gehe und der sequenziert dann erstmal mein Genom oder hat das
so und guckt dann, okay, was ist, was ist nicht in Ordnung und äh ja schmeißt dann,
den ja,
Printer oder Synthesiser, an der dann ähm gezielt
irgendwelche ja RNA Vektor
Dinge produziert, sodass mein Körper es perfekt in der Lage fast alle Medikamente eigentlich selber zu produzieren, die es so zu kaufen gibt, wenn man den Zellen nur den Bauplan dafür gibt.
Das heißt, eigentlich gibt's gar keinen Grund, jetzt Pillen zu schluck.
In der fortgeschrittenen Gesellschaft, sondern ich gehe zum Arzt, dann rechnet der Computer und dann ähm kriege ich anschließend eine Pille, die schlucke ich und dann ja macht der Rest eigentlich meinen Körper.
Wie das Beispiel mit der Zuckerkrankheit.
Nicht zuckerkrankheit, sondern Laktoseintoleranz.
Laktose, genau, ne? Aber auch das äh ist ja unter Umständen auch noch so ein so ein Bereich äh ne und Krebsforschung et cetera. Also,
das ist äh genau das ist so der der Ausblick den man denn ist glaube ich hier äh durchaus wagen kann
Nicht, dass es nächstes Jahr schon soweit ist, aber wir machen auf jeden Fall signifikante Fortschritte auf Basis eines anderen signifikanten Fortschritts, nämlich eben dieses Maschinenlearning, was eben mit den Katzenbildern seinen Durchbruch hatte.
Ja und um jetzt den den Kovit-Bezug nochmal zu kriegen und herzustellen äh es ist vielleicht insofern dann
positiv, dass jetzt diese Pandemie gekommen ist, weil die definitiv nochmal der ganzen Forschung in dem Bereich äh auch nochmal einen gewaltigen Schub,
geben hat. Also wenn es was Gutes gibt,
so an Kovit, dann ist es, dass es nicht definitiv so den den Fortschritt befördert und dass ich mir gut vorstellen kann, dass das, was jetzt an Fortschritten gemacht wird, auch für die Behandlung
anderer Krankheiten ähm einen deutlichen Schub zur Folge haben wird.
Dort, dass man bereit ist, hier Investitionen zu leisten, weil es einfach.
Weil der Nutzen sichtbar geworden ist und weil die, weil die Fortschritte so greifbar äh sind, ne. Es ist alles in der in einer Art und Weise in den Fokus gekommen, wie man sich das sonst nicht hätte vorstellen können. Das stimmt.
Ja, gut, dann müssen wir langsam mal hier zum äh Ende kommen. Die Sendung ist schon äh sehr lang,
Stellte Skips übrigens in Berlin jetzt auch äh hier im im KitKat Club, ne? Das fand ich ja mal ein interessantes äh Businessmodell, ne? Also wenn ein Laden sowieso nicht mehr aufmachen kann, also Kidka Club äh nicht weiß, was es ist, das ist halt hier so ein Berliner
Club, der so als Fetisch äh Laden bekannt ist, wo also wo so.
Na ja, wie soll ich sagen? Dein deine deine sexuelle Präferenz äh gewürdigt wird und ähm.
Die können natürlich derzeit nicht ihren normalen Betrieb durchführen, wie man sich vorstellen kann.
Also haben sie quasi ihren Club jetzt einfach in so einen Schnelltestladen umgewandelt, haben sich dann ein entsprechendes medizinisches Personal rangeholt und haben halt dann diese Schnelltest und da kann man da einfach mal hin für fünfundzwanzig Euro
Probe entnommen und kann dann äh sich mal schnell testen lassen. So, äh, auch ganz nett.
Ansonsten müssen wir nochmal gucken, welche Auswirkungen das alles noch auf uns haben wird.
Unter anderem hat es ja auf Amazon Reviews Auswirkungen. Das fand ich ja auch eine geile Meldung.
Dass jemand hat das mal untersucht, was ähm wie sich diese Reviews ähm von.
Aromakerzen, ja.
Duftkerzen, Aromakerzen äh entwickelt haben im Jahr
zwanzigzwanzig und hat auch eine Kontrollgruppe, nämlich die äh normalen Kerzen und man stellt fest, also es war glaube ich im Wesentlichen auf äh Amazon äh USA ähm bezogen
das im Jahr zwanzig zwanzig Duftkerzen einfach.
Im zunehmenden Maße schlechter bewertet wurden. Man kann sich schon denken, warum? Weil die Leute einfach nicht mehr so gut riechen durch die ganzen äh Corona-Infektionen und sich wundern, warum
Duftkerzen so scheiße geworden sind dieses Jahr. Da sind sie die symptomatischen Fälle. Man kann sie direkt aus den.
Also die sagen sie hat.
Speziell wurden die Zahl der Reviews wo erwähnt wurde dass diese Kerze gar nicht duftet.
So, die waren bei zwei Prozent im Januar und sind auf sechs Prozent im November gestiegen und.
Monatlich folgen sie's, folgten sie so der ersten Welle und jetzt der zweiten Welle, wie man sich das, wenn man sich das anschaut.
Darüber können wir die nächste Panne Welle dann auch gleich feststellen. Oh, die Reviews werden schon wieder schlechter.
Und es gibt wohl auch irgendjemand anders, der das dann für äh für Parfüm gemacht mit.
Etwas schwächeres Signal, aber man sieht halt auch diese Kurve so die erste Welle, danach geht's runter und dann die zweite äh Welle, so das korrespondiert eigentlich ganz gut. So ja, das,
fand ich wirklich so.
Kein gutes Jahr für Duftkerzen auf jeden Fall. Das kann man festhalten.
Ich.
Gut Pavel.
Ja, haben wir wieder einen ganz guten.
Galopp, also ja man kann feststellen, wie er, wie gesagt, hoffnungslos, aber nicht ernst. Die Situation.
Und ja man wir positiv so in Berlin ist das Gesundheitssystem nicht zusammengebrochen und wird es auch,
erstmal nicht jedenfalls nicht in den nächsten Wochen, äh wie es aussieht und hoffentlich auch nicht danach. Aber
umgekehrt gibt's halt gerade ein wenig Hoffnung
auf äh Lockerungen ähm wobei sicherlich einige Landesteile oder Landkreise gibt.
Wo man sagen könnte, okay, da ist tatsächlich nicht viel los, aber äh die kann man dann fast an einer Hand abzählen. Wobei
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern äh und Schleswig-Holstein
sind unter fünfzig, aber äh so richtig runter unter dreißig oder auf zwanzig
kommen, die halt im Moment auch noch nicht insofern würde ich selbst in den Ländern jetzt eigentlich von Lockerungen absehen wollen und die Politik, wenn man
in die Medien gerade guckt macht uns gerade auch wenig Hoffnung auf Lockerung. Also ich hab,
irgendwie nirgendwo jetzt gehört in der Presse, wir lockern sogar auch für Berlin, ist jetzt in in der Diskussion dann Weihnachten dann auch nicht diese,
geplanten Erleichterung zu machen, sondern halt auch über Weihnachten die Beschränkung auf fünf Leute aus zwei Haushalten.
Äh weiter aufrechtzeiten. Bin gespannt, wie das ausgeht.
Macht euch, macht euch alles schon mal ein Zoom Account, ihr werdet ihn brauchen, Weihnachten äh kann man glaube ich vorm Laptop dann doch ganz entspannt verbringen,
Ich meine, jetzt haben wir schon irgendwie alles remote gemacht. Jetzt kann man irgendwie Weihnachten auch nochmal durchexerzieren. Und am Ende könnte das äh eurem psychischen Zustand auch ganz zuträglich sein aus verschiedenen Gründen, weil für viele Leute ist Weihnachten,
Belastung. Es wird immer so hochgejubelt, wie was es doch für ein tolles äh Fest ist aus Leute, die sind mal ganz froh sind.
Vorbei.
Es ist natürlich die alte traditionelle Sonnenwindfeier so nach Weihnachten wird alles besser, werden die Tage wieder länger und es kommt wieder Licht und es ist eigentlich
hattest den Zweck so diese dunkle graue
kalte, nasse Jahreszeit, so ein wenig zu erhellen und äh ja inwieweit das gelingt äh in der Tat. Ich meine, ich bin, ich finde jetzt Weihnachten nicht schlimm
aber ich könnte auch ehrlich gesagt drauf verzichten. So Silvester wird mir völlig ausreichen so um irgendwie ja.
So besser kann ich auch verzichten. Ich kann auf alles verzichten. Ich will jetzt hier nur äh das wir vorankommen, dass wir irgendwie nicht so viele Leute umbringen und dass wir äh uns hier mal ordentlich durchgeimpft bekommen, damit wir zumindest einen entspannten Sommer haben. Und das wird dann, um mal.
Sendung auch wirklich mal mit einer positiven Note beenden. Das wird der geilste S.
Ich ja.
Wir werden die noch nie so zu schätzen gewusst haben wie wie dieses Mal und das äh finde ich es doch auch mal.
Ja können wir hoffen, dass ja äh alle die jetzt in zwanzig zwanzig gelitten haben auch an wirtschaftlichen Einbußen, dass das dann zwanzig einundzwanzig dann wieder ein bisschen.
Kompensiert werden.
Oder richtig durch die Decke geht. Ne? Okay. Das war's Leute. Wir sagen tschüss, bis nächste Woche.